this is the first animal we've ever had
on sets
hey welcome to another episode of the
trash taste podcast i'm joey and i'm
with gun connor and i'm with this person
who are you i'm jessica and i am this
person how's it going just again i'm
miss person hello so yeah where was
jessica igri hello how's it going i'm
super good how are you thank you for
having me yeah no worries thank you for
coming down yeah cause you don't live in
l.a no we drove in from um arizona with
uh ryan my boyfriend and my doggy cardo
hey yeah we we posted a picture on
twitter yeah you saw of carter wearing
the trash taste bandana that you made i
did without our consent i'm sorry
i'm afraid i'm afraid now people are
gonna think we've actually gotten a dog
no i've already seen the replies and
people like they've got a dog
podcast confirmed we can barely take
care of the podcast
yeah we can't take care of a dog so uh i
guess explain to people who are watching
this who perhaps may not know who you
are and what you do i'm an elder hoe
i've been around
i've been around is that the technical
term
i've been around for a long time i've
done cosplay i've done voice acting i've
done
i've done some stuff i can't talk about
that i can tell you guys off camera
it's not weird but it's cool um
[ __ ] i've just been around for a really
long time and i'm very grateful that i'm
still around
[Music]
[Applause]
how did you get your start because i
didn't even know yeah
it was all a mistake it was all it was
it was the pikachu cosplay
yeah okay so i i would like grew up with
like i grew up getting bullied [ __ ] for
liking anime and all that stuff like
yeah like we all do and now anime is
cool what the hell's up with that very
cool
but i'm i'm a little bitter um
but like it's it's uh so i i well i was
growing up liking all that stuff and
everything and then my friend was like
my birthday and he bought me a ticket
standing at comic-con and he was like do
you want to go to san diego what year
was this uh 2009.
yeah
bro i met uh oh my gosh she's so lovely
nihachu and we were talking about steph
and she goes i was telling her about
everything and she goes oh i was born in
2001 and i was like
wait how old is everybody here
uh i'm 25. he's the young one he's the
youngest he's 25 i'm 27. i'm 32.
hey that's my girl
we're gonna die first let's go we're
gonna be in the ground
um
yes anyway sorry i got distracted um
go to go to san diego comic con i look
it up beforehand and uh i see that
people dress up for it and so i was like
oh [ __ ] okay i love pokemon i'll draw
you gonna do it
he's just dying to crack up
so off camera jessica uh
drank our first white claw which we
bought a crate of this and then nobody's
drunk it at all
uh i only noticed this i was saying a
gun earlier right uh i had a white claw
before and i don't have a great
experience with it but then i just
noticed on the can it says spiked
sparkling water yeah i don't know if the
word spiked is a good marketing word
usually that means like oh [ __ ] someone
spiked my drink like yeah it's going
down so so this is like claiming the
words yeah this is like the drink that i
see everyone in [ __ ] la and
california drink uh 100 calories
alcoholic water it's alcoholic lacroix
fresh i don't even know what la croix is
looking you do not you do know what it's
like it's like someone farted in the
room next door and some of that fart got
into your drink somehow in your open
glass on the table
it's like if you got sparkling water and
you sprayed perfume on it yes all right
that's what that's like it's this is
just that with the whole and jessica
loves it for some reason yeah so i like
this one when you get older you gotta
worry about when when in l.a am i right
boys
cheers
this does not taste good
okay put a little bit of something else
on there
i think it's cute
oh it's like essence of mango it's like
it's like they had sparkling water and
they just put a mango next to it for
dinner
i get it it's a hundred calories two
cranberries yeah yeah yeah it's no carbs
i get that yeah but it doesn't taste
good i would rather just drink water
yeah you know let's let's just call it
what it is it's just alcoholic water
right no one's drinking no one's
drinking this for the taste because they
want to know what it is
they like that alcohol unless you do i
do i like the taste of alcohol which is
which one name which one you like right
now name all alcohol i like taste like
wine and sake yeah it depends what type
of wine though like dessert wine
oh no oh you like your sweet drinks
you just like sweet drinks a lot of
sugar a lot of sugar yeah i like red
you like red wine yeah
well but like i grew an appreciation
towards red wine and i'd say the past
like three or four years okay
with sake as well yeah same same with me
i grew an appreciation yeah yeah
i'm like i can afford this one is really
depressing when you're broke because
it's it comes in bags and boxes and
you're like
i disagree i disagree though because
like i didn't realize how much cheaper
wine was in europe compared to japan
where it is expensive yeah but in europe
it just tastes so much better and you
can buy something
yeah but like as a student you just want
to get far like drunk as fast as
possible so wine just wasn't in your
vocabulary no it was it wasn't australia
we had goon bags which is just like
boxed wine it was [ __ ]
nothing more
how did they form a country that's just
that that was like that was like the
cheap like you're a broke college
student yeah it was just goon there is
nothing more depressing than box one it
looks depressing it wasn't even wine it
was just grape flavored hand sanitizer
[Music]
i worked on a vineyard for a while when
i was like 18 in marlborough in new
zealand yeah
hello how about how did that happen my
uh my aunt and i like lived with my aunt
and my uncle down in new zealand for a
while because like we were going back
and forth when i when we moved in
australia yeah yeah yeah your accent
just kind of shifted them they aren't oh
dude like my voice is going to be like
yeah because not many people know but
you're originally from
okay so i was
born in new zealand i was no i was born
in reno
all right so my mom is from new zealand
and my dad is from the states right and
she came over to the states and met my
dad and then she was like come over to
new zealand and then they like come over
and then uh they went back and forth so
they had me and my older brother in reno
and then we moved and then when i was
like so i don't remember anything about
reno but then we moved to new zealand
and they had my little brother james
right and how long did you live in new
zealand for so i lived there from like
three to twelve so like my entire
formative like use of like who i am is
there okay so like blinky bill and all
that kind of stuff and like [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah
like so i don't know like what what like
gumby is like when i moved over here i
didn't know have all those like
established american like right like uh
like childhood
shows and everything and it was really
weird so it's oceana things i guess
going back to
how dare you
what are you talking about
did you celebrate the silvage no the
jubilee the diamond jubilee like we did
sorry [ __ ] oh my gosh
though
yeah i mean just because you get an
excuse to get drunk and blow [ __ ] up
the vines um yes so i went to comic-con
and i dressed i looked it up beforehand
and i was like what do people do when
they go to comic-con
uh they dress up so i was like [ __ ] i
love pokemon i'm gonna dress up as like
a sexy pikachu style thing
i went to uh i went to comic con
that was insane i don't think i've ever
had you like you know those um
those uh cosplay events where they have
like um the girls in japan and they're
like standing there and there's like a
wall of photographers yeah similar
situation with me like way back then so
my introduction to everything was just
hard fast
just
like right off the bat and i had my
actual like full name and everything on
my badge right so like when people took
photos they could just zoom in and they
saw like jessica negri and
you know
and uh so that went like i would say
like viral back in the day for 2009 you
know and then they found me on facebook
oh no yeah but your personal face my
personal facebook and i found my family
and everything and i was like [ __ ] so at
the time i was like i'm gonna make a
facebook page so that i can protect
everybody in my life yeah and redirect
everyone to this thing so it was a
complete fluke i wasn't like some
master like oh now that i've acquired
the internet cloud it's time to focus
into the facebook page it was like oh
[ __ ] my family make a facebook page and
lock everything down yeah and then
everything just started to just snowball
like crazy and i was just like [ __ ] yeah
because you kind of i remember you kind
of came into existence on the internet
almost overnight yes
it was like really fast i remember i got
interviewed by my founding fathers kasim
g yeah oh yeah i remember that
holy [ __ ] i was going to say that yeah
the first time i saw you was ksmg yeah
philip philip defranco for me and then
and then i discovered kasem g after yeah
yeah never forget those are my boys
my dads yeah no so they're they're
they're the ones that kind of like
shot it into trade trajectory
trajectory there we go and then uh every
year after that me and uh like hassan
would be like do you want to do an
interview and then so we would do like
interviews with like california on
comic-con with castle and stuff and
started to just do this consistent thing
and i was having a fun time and i was
working at trader joe's in the dollar
store at the same time
and uh i was like i was like [ __ ] man oh
this is getting a little
getting a little crazy i don't know if i
can work at both jobs like while i'm
doing this and then i just started to
speed run you know right really cool
speed run speed run you know
how did you transition like how how long
was it than a hobby for you before it
became a job because it sounds like you
just did like one random cosplay then
everything just exploded all out so i've
tried my hardest to never look at it as
like and this is going to sound really
cliche and i'm sure everyone says like
oh you never work a day in your life
when you're waiting 80 hours a week for
yourself
but like i tried my hardest to
not look at as a job and every costume
that i've made or whatever that wasn't
like hired by a company or something i
was like i want this to be something
that i want to do right i'm like i want
to hang out and have fun and like when i
would go do those interviews with kasim
i wanted to have fun and like talk to
him and be like i [ __ ] love castle
you know yeah so it would be that kind
of energy going forward and then i think
it was when i did the audition for the
lollipop chainsaw thing yeah oh yeah
yeah so um they were doing this like
back in 2012
literally 10 years ago like a week ago
um they were doing this ign search for
juliette starling and a friend of mine
was like bro you should go do this you
love pseudo51 you love no more heroes
you love james gunn you love slither all
those like [ __ ] up movies and stuff
and i was like okay and so then i went
and i made the juliet starling costume
and i went to go interview and i
remember i was interviewing with these
oh my like these women were so pretty
and i was just being like i'm never
gonna get this i'm never gonna [ __ ]
get this and then i remember i did the
interview
and i like i flubbed like i flubbed the
audition like crazy so i keep hitting
you i'm so sorry it's okay it doesn't
pick it up at all um i i flipped the
interview like hardcore
and i was like i [ __ ] this
that's fine i had a great time what a
great time you know and then uh i found
out that i had won
which was really [ __ ] cool so was it
a competition or was it yeah so what
they did is they did like a it was like
a search for juliet starling like a
representative of like
this is the person who's most like them
yeah and like i said because what i what
you do is like you do like this voting
thing and so what i did is i did a photo
shoot and then i would put them on the
facebook page
and then people would vote for me and
stuff or like and like you could vote
like a certain amount of times a day and
so i was like guys go folks i got all my
friends piled up in like zombie costumes
and like just stood on top of them with
a chainsaw and was like whoa you know
like did the whole shoot it was it was
really cool such a good game as well
such a good game have you played
lollipop chainsaw no
it's really good it's from 2012 though
so go in with that
it's an oldie now yeah
it's a pseudo51 game and they're all so
crazy it was voting but it was also like
judges decide so yeah so so what we did
is they did the voting for like the
broad thing for a bunch of people across
the thing and then it was like okay and
then it brought you in kind of right
right yeah this is really serious for
just a competition to find someone who
looks like a character it was it was
really extensive yeah i think they
wanted someone to be kind of like the
face but they're also like professional
also like do they still do stuff like
that nowadays i don't know i don't
really hear about it anymore yeah i
think that was like the early days you
know where yeah cosplaying was just
starting to become a thing yeah yeah
like that's too worried about people
getting cancelled and stuff you know
maybe companies have shied away from
having like one guy as their oh yeah
yeah
i guess as well it's like kind of like
an inclusivity or like exclusivity
problem i guess where it's like oh only
one person is allowed to cosplay this
yeah
yeah i was thinking about that the other
day and i was like that's a really very
uniquely like uh early 2000s kind of
like yeah yeah
like hey girl you want to come interview
chainsaw girl and i was like yeah you
know like
well whatever how big was the cosplay
scene back then when you started i don't
i want to be like um
because the cosplay scene has been
around for a very long time yeah i think
saying that like
i just happened to kind of come into it
and then i'm very lucky to be able to be
where i am because of it and yeah as a
cosplay i am a fan of cosplay yeah but i
would never say like oh cosplay is now a
thing because of like whatever but
because because of me yeah like that's i
think that's like the the complete
wrong way to look at it yeah has always
been such a huge huge subculture of
comic con and everything like that
massively talented creators and people
putting their all into costumes and
everything um back then it was a lot
smaller i think with
the pandemic and everything popping off
and everyone accessibility to costumes
and everything is popped off like [ __ ]
oh yeah i can imagine yeah yeah but like
back then it was it was indeed
smaller well i i guess it makes sense
because back then just not even anime
but just like nerd culture in general
just wasn't as big as it is now so i
think i think cosplay the cosplay scene
has just grown with how the mainstream
has viewed this kind of culture yes
something like that
so there's just like a lot more there's
a lot more people doing it now
do you feel like the barrier of entry is
still just as easy as it was before oh
honestly i i'm like there are there are
two wolves inside me because like i feel
like cosplays split off into
like the super hardcore like crafting
people who are like yeah you've been
around and like make their own stuff and
everything and then there's like this
super accessible all-inclusive [ __ ] that
is so good like when i look at cosplay
my mind goes costume play and i don't
like and the accessibility to costumes
has become
so amazing these past couple years and
to be able to see more people just be
able to like throw in a costume become
their favorite person in the world is
like
that's pretty cool the coolest [ __ ] ever
i've noticed as well that like just like
even if you can't make your own cosplays
anymore just like buying cosplays has
become cheaper yes oh my god like it's
become because i remember there was a
point where like you would look up a
cosplay even in japan of like a school
uniform or something and it was like you
know two three hundred dollars plus yeah
now you can get a school uniform for
like as cheap as like you know 40 bucks
have you seen the
[Laughter]
you go to a convention and you're like
yo that guy's wearing an akatsuki cloak
yo he's got [ __ ] on lockdown man that
looks so cool so how did you where did
you get that from
i want that
there are times where i miss those days
because i'm like oh so like underground
and if like you saw a really really cold
costume like you like you had to have
made that you know yeah again there are
two balvarines inside of me and that is
that there is accessibility now which
makes it so much better yeah 3d printing
right as i imagine that's been like a
big thing the 3d printing game is insane
i have some friends who literally have a
space like this and it's just lined with
walls of 3d printers wow mindy smalls
she has like like 10 3d printers and she
can be like oh you want a full cosplay
and she'll like print it out and she'll
like
crazy it's so amazing
i didn't know i didn't know 3d printing
had gotten that good or you could just
kind of make like
could you make a whole costume which is
3d printed absolutely yeah if you take
the time to like sculpt it and then like
size it to your body absolutely wow yeah
it's incredible game changer yeah so
like how long did it take you to like
learn your skills in cosplaying i guess
because my mom taught me actually your
mom told me yeah because my mom my mom
did hats for the um like uh like uh
what's what's it called it's it's like
the kentucky derby but it's like in new
zealand so it's like the new zealand so
it's like little baby baby new zealand
derby you know so she'd make like those
big hats and stuff like that she won a
couple competitions and she did this
thing in new zealand called the
world of wearable arts
which is like if you're from new zealand
you know it's like this competition
where bunch of people and artists will
make like wearable things and send them
off to models to wear and then they do
like the cats
it's really [ __ ] cool so she she has
a very creative streak to her so does my
dad like right um but she taught me how
to sew and like she helped me with like
my super super old school dark magician
girl from like way way back in the day
oh my god yeah it was so cool yeah oh my
god you said you just had all the skill
sets just like pre-programmed
like mother i would like to pursue
cosplay teach me how to solve
all right well it's time to get a big
push-up bra and we'll contour the boobs
and send me off
thank you mum oh my god or like some of
you like your most challenging early
cosplays to do then [ __ ] i like um it
kind of i was like how long did the
pikachu one take like [ __ ]
i mean i was gonna say compared to some
of your laser cosplays that seems like a
very simple cosplay the wrong guy
the right way
oh my god yeah yeah
oh yeah what were the what were the
toughest ones that you remember
um probably my sindragosa cosplay was
probably really oh yeah yeah i uh me and
my friend zach designed it together and
then i i made it and it was like the
reason why it was so tough was because
there's so many [ __ ] scales and like
so many little bits and pieces and
everything that were just like yeah
stack and i was like this is just
how do you decide where you're going to
cosplay it seems like you kind of do
like all the stuff that you wouldn't
expect i love i have to love it i have
to be the pyramid head i watched the
video where you made it oh that was that
was so cool
pyramid head could tear me apart
throw me to the side of the church
and use my blood to create a mural of
his close intimate and personal
relationship
and i would be thankful yeah i think my
recent favorite one of yours was the
chainsaw man when you do oh that was so
fun that's why we should do music
because my brother does music he did all
the uh the the music for that oh really
ryan did the guttural chainsaw oh sick
yeah ryan did like full death metal
growl and everything like that oh yeah
you'd be really good at that little
growling i heard your death the other
day
so anyways do you want to see me
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hi i'm connor i'm reading for the part
of scream
[Laughter]
[Music]
but speaking about voices you you did
the voice for super sonico as well
completely forgot about that
so i did like some work some cosplay
work for sentai film works
and uh they were super i [ __ ] loved
it they're so lovely yeah um they were
really nice and they were like hey we're
looking for an english voice actor do
you want to be the voice of super sonico
and i was like
i'm not a voice actor but okay
um
man voice acting is so hard
it is so funny did you have like zero
voice acting experience before i had
like i think i did a little bit of like
cinder fall for monty
i [ __ ] love you monty monty had so
much faith in me
um but uh that's like the only
experience that i had and then i did
super sonico
how was that
i haven't i haven't listened to it i
mean you sounded good
i think
i think
i don't know maybe it's because maybe
it's because when i watched super sonica
i knew it was you yes you were giving me
that and i was just like that's jessica
you know let's go
let's go okay so you're looking at me
like like a proud parent yeah like like
like a friend had just smelled something
cool you know what was the general
consensus
i don't think
if i could redo it i would love to
because i feel like
these days i i would for what it was and
the skills that i had back then
it was what i could do you know i think
if i did it now it would be so much
better because i think you just learn so
much more as you get older yeah there's
like so many different ways to like
adjust your voice and your tone and
everything even with cinder fall you
listen to cinder in the first couple
seasons and then cinder now the change
is like so different oh yeah yeah
yeah like very quickly yeah like i wish
i wish i had like had what i i wish i
could do now what i do then this this
version of me back then everyone's gonna
start somewhere right exactly yeah
especially that was like one of your
first big starters in a big show yeah
yeah which was pretty magnets and then
they had me back for the video game too
wow and so i was just like are you sure
they're like yeah it works around the
first time yeah yeah yeah you'll be
right like do not get me wrong i am so
incredibly appreciative that i got to do
that like yeah yeah like what an insane
that's an opportunity not many people
care yeah especially for their first
role like oh my god did you deal with
any criticism at all from like people
being like oh my gosh she only got it
because she's popular i'm sure yeah i i
i honestly i don't really look at too
much stuff yeah the real question is did
you give a [ __ ]
small idea like there's a there's a part
of me there are there are two worgens
inside me and uh
it's a [ __ ] weird t-shirt where it's
like there are two wolves inside of me
and it's one of them's like i'm in a
sigma they look like i'm gay
this is the best of all i'm saying it
was good it was good
um
what was i saying where did i go about
the voice acting oh uh i'm no with uh so
with like seeing criticisms like that i
usually like try to just
stay away from like looking at that kind
of stuff yeah yeah because i know that
it would just destroy me it i also it
also applies though with like numbers
and stuff like that right so i apply
that whole kind of mentality and blanket
to everything right pretty healthy
i think it has helped me really a lot
because uh i remember talking to phil
like way back in the day
and uh he he said something like that
and he was like you know just kind of
you know what goes up must come down
right so prepare yourself and i was like
oh okay so then if i just never kind of
know how big or small
then i won't be
like sad when it's no longer a thing you
know yeah i'm glad you took it that way
because it could have easily taken it as
well if i just never go down oh my god
well yeah like i do i do see that people
cause some people think it's like that
right
even if you have a general upwards
trajectory there's always like months or
weeks right it goes down of course
you're like i'm falling off
and you have to have that like full
conversation with yourself is like no my
content's not who i am yeah you know and
you have to you have to have that real
like real real real therapy session do
you guys do therapy no voice
voice
do you exercise let's exercise our mind
i exercise okay okay
also i exercise my mind he doesn't
exercise you need to get him on it i
don't physically exercise i mentally
exercise
i exercise in my mind which is exactly
the same as physical activity i know how
to solve a rubik's cube but that was
pretty sick
i've never done therapy even if i wanted
to right let's say i wanted to get a
therapist in japan
yeah i've i've heard of some therapists
in japan that speak english and i've
heard horrible horrible things oh i
didn't even think of that yeah it's
really really hard to find i've done
therapy before and it's like since
moving to japan it's almost like
impossible to find like an in-person
therapist if you want to do it it's
probably got to be online and it's i
wonder if that's a good option because
there was um a time where like i was
talking to someone online and it was
like it was so nice to talk about just
to get like validated in your feelings
and stuff like that just to get certain
things yeah it definitely is helpful but
i feel like you do lose a little bit
like not being there in person you know
there's there is body language that they
read because they online that it feels
like there is like a wall like like you
don't you don't really feel like you
talk to a person sometimes even though
you know there's a person on the other
side there's just especially when you're
talking about some really really
intimate things just like that extra
connection and the extra like human
connection like can really help i feel
also you know you run the risk of like
pouring your heart out and then they'll
just be like oh sorry the connection
what did you say you know you don't want
that in a therapy session pov australian
internet
sorry i'm in australia uh what did you
say could you read that
sorry my wife's calling me give me a sec
yeah you don't want that yeah yeah so
what is like the process of making a
cosplay because my all of my experience
and knowledge comes from watching
dress-up darling and that and that's it
and i like know nothing about what goes
on behind the scenes basically in terms
of making a costume
no that's fair um actually yeah it had a
lot of like stuff that was uh
pretty accurate yeah like um the
research phase and stuff like that
getting a guy that will do it for you
getting a boredom
make this for me no um doing a lot of
like the the planning process or
honestly before that finding something
that you're in love with okay because i
feel like 90 of the time when you're
like in that cosplay crunch and you want
to like throw everything out and you're
like this is [ __ ] balls i hate this
[ __ ] your love of the character drags
you through the glass you know and you
go like oh i [ __ ] love this i don't
[ __ ] care like i i need like no no
sleep you know i'm gonna do this how
much time do you normally put into a
costume it can depend it really depends
i have like a a mental timer it's about
one to two weeks
where if i like if i'm gone beyond that
i will forget about it i made a
gentleman cho'gath and it took longer
than two weeks and they disappeared and
i don't know
again
because she disappeared because i i
didn't finish it because i had the i had
the stiletto feet and everything sounds
so good i had the [ __ ]
there's a monster from league of legends
yeah it's like [ __ ] oh yeah that's
why you're so great that's why i don't
need a therapist
that's why he's happy that's why i'm
happy that's why he doesn't need therapy
okay exactly
yes
i did i did okay i did it's true
and then i've been league-free
oh no i've been getting back at the
a-rams lately and it's been great this
episode is sponsored by apari now you
may have heard of aparri because if you
bought some of our trash taste merch
well these are the guys who made it
apari is an artist-owned apparel brand
featuring original artwork you can wear
as you can see right here connor and
gone are wearing the ox and i am wearing
this uh brand new tiger one look at this
it is very important
it is very very interesting i gotta say
you've seen me wear this in a bunch of
videos in the past yeah right now
because it's summer but normally i'd
wear the heck out of this thing cause
it's so soft such good quality guys of
course the material was gonna be good
because we would have never partnered
with them in the first place if it
wasn't and you'll be happy to know that
aparri right now is doing a brand new
drop of brand new pieces these
particular items you see on screen right
now will be available for pre-order
along with the launch of other items
such as the button downs and t-shirts
and their t-shirts as well are super
comfy super durable great quality stuff
and that is a trash taste guaranteed as
well and the button downs are really
nice and silky because they're made from
eucalyptus and bamboo fibers
so if you want to get yourself dripped
out with some more parry merch click the
link in the description to check them
out back to the episode um where were we
legends causes therapy yes
you were talking about how you were
making your cosplay before that before
you got distracted yes yeah so one to
two week timer of like how long i can
work on something just because i i
personally don't want to put that much
like energy into something and then you
know cause like there is a time where
you can become too hyper focused on
something and it can like
make you go a little nuts because then
you're like you're ultra focused on all
the different details and you're just
kind of like
what so you gotta let it go you know let
it go you gotta send it out in the
universe right yeah so it's usually
about that and then you like the
creation process is like i've seen you
post like you did the iron mouse one
recently and you were like you were like
oh my god by the way yeah i was awesome
yeah and you did it you like it's a
quick cosplay what was the speed run
what was that how fast like uh like like
four or five days i would uh ryan's back
in here but i would like
i was like i think i was watching like
xqc gamble or something
i was just like
the whole time you weren't even watching
so i didn't want to like i didn't want
to i did watch mouse but like i didn't
want to like like do that in case it
would like i don't know i don't distract
you from yeah because her stuff is so
cute and so she makes i don't know i
love her as a content creator she
inspires the ever-loving [ __ ] out of me
yeah her her attitude about everything
and just like the way that she tackles
everything going on i'm just like
you're [ __ ] awesome yeah yeah she is
greeting shout out to hahn mouse
i am going to send it to her too
so what do you say she said that yeah
yeah so when you said one to two weeks
it is one to two weeks full on every day
you wake up you do costume you sleep oh
my god
i mean i guess that's become your
job at this point right yeah but it's
it's like a it's like giving birth and
then uh
i need you to finish that sentence right
now you bring a baby into this yeah it's
like taking a big poop and then you do
it and then and then you want to like
take a break
yeah
and then i then i usually like go you
got to raise it up you know you know
what i assume like you know taking
pictures and doing all that stuff also
takes a long time yes yeah so ryan will
actually take my photos and then we'll
send it off to someone to edit either
martin or a friend robbie and like
that's that's really i'm so lucky that
ryan is able to take my photos too
because it's like a comfortability thing
as well so if i'm like ryan take a photo
of my [ __ ] he's like a baby
spread it
oh my god
is that a normal topic absolutely
i've i've i've been on a photo shoot
with jessica in hawaii oh yeah the one
at the waterfall that's right was i in
my gnar or my bulge in i think it was
your vulgen one
yeah warchief
i don't play wife oh the warchief i made
a volgin cosplay and i did a photo shoot
in a waterfall in hawaii you gotta go to
hawaii hawaii yeah i love you i went
with you
i was there
i was literally there with you on that
show oh man that was so fun so yeah it's
like it's it's pretty full on like you
get into your cosplay and you're kind of
like in the zone because depending on
like how you made things because when i
make stuff quick sometimes it like
really hurts me when i work i don't take
the time to like make it comfortable and
so then we do the shoot
and then usually like if there's with
this particular case like we went to the
convention right after right which was
rough yeah because like we got up and we
like airbrushed in the hotel and then we
went to the the jungle took photos and
then
came back touched up again and then went
to the convention for like eight hours
or whatever
that whole convention experience was
rough
because every morning jess would be like
we're doing something i know i'm like
six in the morning and i'm like and and
aki and i were like we have to do a
panel in like four hours it's just like
i don't give a [ __ ]
didn't you go like hiking or something
three hours before your panel oh there's
oh my god this is like the toughest
morning of my life all right so it was
like the second to last i think it was
like one of the busiest days in the
corner i was like saturday it was the
saturday baby
uh uh what was it amazing hawaii comic
con i'm at aways and quiet comic-con
that's right on honolulu um and uh it
was like six in the morning and just was
like we're gonna go hiking
and i'm like uh okay but we have to be
back at the convention in like you know
like nine or ten or whatever i think it
was like yeah it was like ten it was
like ten or something and she's like no
it'll be an easy hike so then we drive
out like an hour
to this mountain called coco head which
is on uh
like one of the hardest climbs i've ever
done in my life because the entire
mountain is like a 50 degree incline so
it's it's a it's a mountain that was
originally a lookout post to at the top
of the hill they had a train track that
would go up yeah like directly straight
up and then on top was like a lookout
and you could see out of the ocean that
was cool so what they did is they
removed the train track and so now you
can walk up it as a hike but it gets but
at some points when when you get to the
top of it it gets so steep you literally
have to use the train tracks as a ladder
to climb yeah that sounds good
it's it's great it's so good it's great
is that just like a light walk for you
jess
yeah every day she got up in like 15
minutes
meanwhile aki and i are like because
we're not used to it right so we're just
like [ __ ] struggling
though well she was dead at the top
there's this great photo where it's like
all of us just like with this amazing
view of hawaii just like this and then
in the corner you can just see aki face
down on the ground just dead
and then jess is like don't worry i got
you she pulls out a five hour energy and
just like feeding it to her she just
springs up and she's like i'm ready to
go
oh my god this is just [ __ ] bolts
down the mountain i love aki the whole
time i was like dude do you want to you
know you want to turn around she goes
she goes no no i want to do this
like she was so determined for no reason
she inspired the [ __ ] out of me man i
was like yes yes we will do this we will
ride you know like i was so [ __ ]
pumped because aki was so pumped she was
like no no no no no go ahead you go
ahead turn around come back go ahead
all right and then she almost died yeah
she was like oh man how hard was it
it was pretty hot that day as well
because it was pretty
literally like august right when is
hawaii halloween i think it's i think
it's in august
it's like i remember it was really
freaking hard because like it's hawaii
so like i assumed it was so so i just i
just was curious like how hot i was like
dripping sweat yeah
yeah the oceans was beautiful yeah oh my
god the ocean was sick tried to take the
aki into the desk
oh yeah ryan and oculus died
but what happened
so
you almost died
no so we were on we were on waikiki
beach and we were just like hanging out
because we had like a free afternoon or
something right so we're just like yeah
let's just [ __ ] go to the beach yeah
so it was me jess ryan nanaki and then
they were out and then aki was out in
the ocean and then i guess there was
like a really bad current that day right
so she kind of got swept out a little
bit
and and i think ryan immediately saw
that and was like i'm gonna go help her
out yeah ryan went full like terminator
yeah
so ryan so ryan jumps in and grabs her
and then immediately it was kind of like
blocked off by this like a stone wall
right right and then so i guess like so
that you know dangerous wildlife doesn't
come into like this safe area but the
problem was with this stone wall to let
the water come in and out there's like a
little crack
deadly channel yeah and and it's
literally just a channel of water
rushing in and then rushing out over and
over again and but because there was a
current
it just took ryan anakin just
and just swept them out them so quickly
yeah just swept them straight out into
this open water and the entire time jess
and i were just like standing on the
coast just like
oh
it went from like playful laughter to
like genuine concern we had our two
little like a little bottle of malibu
and like orange juice we're standing
there like tourists like oh there goes
ryan no ryan's oh ryan's got him
oh and then the freaking the then the
lifeguard had to come out active
lifeguard comes out it's like the with
the surfboard and everything like put
ryan and aki onto the surf one be like
you guys almost drowned out there we
were like oh meanwhile we were standing
on the beach laughing our ass off with a
malibu
four lifeguards like [ __ ] tourists
yeah yeah
it's like a double rescue yeah i mean
where they like the drink is pouring and
pouring and pouring the lifeguard saves
they're like ryan saves aki
it's like the giant like the domino meme
yes yeah
yeah that was fun though
we should go back yes you guys haven't
been in hawaii oh i really really want
to go it's fun as [ __ ] but you guys were
you guys were lucky you got invited to a
convention that's just a free trip well
aki and i got invited because of jess oh
okay cause jess knows the organization
you should uh bring these cool youtubers
jess look what's up just hook us up hey
jimmy i'm looking at you
bring them there's one specific jimmy it
is jimmy yeah i feel like hawaii is one
of those places you don't need to go to
to know you'll like it you're just like
yeah i just know i like it
the convention scene to there is so
lovely like it was it was really chill
oh my god the people are so [ __ ] cool
and so nice and like you get you get
there and then the immediate vibe is
just like ah
how much time did you spend at the
convention versus just in hawaii
yourself i think we were there for like
six hours a day like at our tables yeah
i think so because yeah it was it was
like four to six hours
because like we did a panel every day
and we did a signing every day so i was
like yeah at least like at least a four
hour like commitment a day but luckily
like all of that stuff was done in the
morning so we would normally be done by
like one or two p.m so that's when they
like split it up yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah two hours in the morning i think
yeah i think they knew that they were
just like we want you to actually just
like go out and enjoy hawaii so we'll
just do all your commitments all at once
and then you can just [ __ ] off and do
whatever you want jimmy you're on a
convention my man jimmy do you wanna you
wanna get them like close to yourself oh
[ __ ] sorry i'm like leaning you're
leaning back so i'm just trying to put
another pillow behind you if you wanna
just
am i full
i did this video where i uh got like a
really expensive cosplay made in japan
and then me made oh created yes sorry
sorry and uh [ __ ] that was hard the
whole the one with uh
yes
that was like made me realize [ __ ]
hell this is awful
this [ __ ] sucks like it was it was a
fun experience because i kind of didn't
need to actually do that much yeah but i
had to keep turning up to like these
sizing things yeah yeah i'm just going
to like six of them yeah and it was like
okay have you haven't you already took
the measurements and it's like resize
and then we size again and then like
don't get fat because we got to size
again in two months and they size me
again like you got fat we got to change
it
yes it was a whole nightmare and then
when i finally got the costume it like
looked good in the photos but like in
real life i was like wow this looks this
sucks
really because of like i think is the
way that it was made it like and the way
that it reflected light not in photos
looks really weird
but also i
like my ass is big and it definitely
wasn't made to have more room
so when i was like sitting down it was
like oh no okay i can't i can't
accommodate the dumpster couldn't
couldn't could not accommodate the dumpy
could not sit down yeah just like i was
like i do not want to do this for more
than two hours yeah
that's so funny i had it off in like two
hours and i was yeah of the thought of
doing this all day made me like want to
faint yeah i was only wearing that iron
mouth costume for like
two hours to like to take the photos and
then i was like
i have like infinite respect for people
at like anime expo or like summer
conventions who are just out in full
[ __ ] cosplay i don't know just like
like because i i think like i don't know
if i don't know if he's going to be
there this year yeah but like i remember
every year at anime expo there is a dude
who dresses up in a full-on gundam
cosplay yeah made out of like cardboard
boxes and just like huge like like you
know he has like the adjustments on his
feet so he stands up a lot taller yeah
and i'm like
how are you standing out here right like
all day it's not covered in cardboard i
remember that one time we went to anime
expo and it was like during the la heat
wave oh yes it was just like definitely
[ __ ] hot and i see people walking
around like full-on armor cosplay i'm
like how are you not dying of heat
that's right that's when guys figured
out guy cosplayers figured out they were
like i could just cosplay as luffy and i
can have an open shirt
it's like barely any fabric on me but
what if you got like a dad bod not
everyone wants to know whoever feels
comfortable
yeah
everyone feels comfortable yeah if he
wants to do it then yeah
where luffy is very full and he has a
big stomach yeah exactly that's kind of
weird yeah so you just say it like that
right he's robber yeah another thing i
found really difficult was posing yes
how the [ __ ] do you learn how to
pose was so annoyed [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
did i do they were like look this way
and then i looked that way and they were
like oh no no no no no
okay so i wonder i wonder because like
uh there are books that you can purchase
what yes there are but they're like in
like cosplay books in japan that you can
purchase and they're like these models
are incredible oh my god when you find a
good pose that you like
that your body like does what you want
it to do you spam the other living [ __ ]
out of that
like it's like an emote right you just
you just spam the emotes every time pose
that i liked with my butt and it would
be like this twisty like leg up thing
that i would do and like it would like
make everything nice and tight here and
then like booty big there and like ryan
would have to get on his knees to
accentuate and everything but i was like
every damn photo shoot we're gonna get
that shot and we're gonna full send it
so i i i i agree but i think posing is
difficult do you think like from like
modeling books or like just like
standard modeling as well or is it a
little bit different i look at like a
lot of like my friends poses and stuff
like that or like people on instagram or
like you know just like on social media
and stuff like some girls just get like
the really good like super like
like lower angles or like yeah was like
a [ __ ] natural yeah she did her thing
and i was like what do i what do i do i
also think when you're in that kind of
industry where you're like your body is
your product you know yeah yeah yeah you
know you need to know kind of like the
vibe of what yeah because when i started
doing modeling shoots i had to buy
modeling books yeah because i didn't
know what the [ __ ] to do we've done one
i was like how do i move my body yeah
wear too is very different kind of
posing right like you have to be really
like kind of like loose i don't even
know what i'm doing yeah exactly we've
done one shoot together and joey [ __ ]
solo carried everything he's just like
do this guy do this and i'm like oh does
this look good goofy i have no [ __ ]
clue because one thing i never got like
one thing i learned on that shoot is
sometimes your body feels really [ __ ]
awkward in like certain poses and you're
like there's no way this is gonna yeah
because like like a really common pose
is to like you know for modeling for
example that i learned is like just
having your hand behind your head like
that yeah no one does that in real life
so when you're doing it
so when you do it in a shoot it's like
this is [ __ ] weird this does not look
good but it always ends up looking good
yeah yeah yeah so it's like that's just
what i've learned the more awkward i
feel while taking a photo and most of
the time it's gonna look good i remember
there was one photo i took where you
were i was like sitting on like the the
chair the stool or something yeah i'm
like i feel like [ __ ] a gremlin right
now just like sitting like this i feel
like hell i'm like there's no way this
is going to look good and somehow it
looks great and somehow luke made it
look really [ __ ] good exactly luke is
very talented like a very talented
photographer yeah good very good i think
you guys looked awesome the was it the
suit shoot that you guys did i thought
you old yeah yeah swag is [ __ ] thank you
did you ever have to take uh inspiration
from like models outside of cosplaying
or oh yeah absolutely i think there's a
lot of like the women before us you know
like
those that walked so we could run when
you said
um yeah no like you take a lot of
inspiration from other like magazines or
like just stuff that you see on tv or
that kind of stuff or even from anime
you try to recreate what uh jojo the
character exactly jojo poses
yeah dude yeah
delicious that reminds me
uh
i got hats
oh yeah you got hats yeah oh yeah i
bought hats but they're like cursed well
i'm not really cursed um we should we
should wear them
all right
i got hats because you guys specifically
you guys are going to be in ariz or in
california and it's going to be really
sunny
outside i figured you know just get a
couple little joke hats you know i like
your hat and i love frogs yeah i do love
frogs
speaking of
this for you
all right all all right all right all
right finally thank you yes how do you
not have that already i do now there you
go there you go i love how i love the
orange as well yeah it's such an ugly
orange it's really ugly
it's really oh
i'm so thank you mom for making me an
only child
where did you get this from i just got
on amazon i was like i was like
i can love mill
guys do you want to take a trip to
alabama quickly yeah
well here in the us okay do you remember
when you were like obsessed with that oh
[ __ ] what up is that boy yeah of course
[ __ ] yeah
oh [ __ ] what up is that boy
oh my god i didn't know they made these
i also have a secondary milf hat if
anybody wants to uh you know change
teams what is it can i say it's it's
black i think you should keep the
original
you need the orange i don't know i don't
look good in hot slopes what are you
talking about looks awesome actually
that suits your shirt
that actually suits you
what the [ __ ] is that boy what the [ __ ]
that she looks like i also got this jojo
i don't know why that's that's why i was
reminded
i don't know here we go
joe jojo and joey's one step closer to
becoming the dad now
[ __ ] what else is that boy
oh my god thank you for my new gift i
actually will use this thank you
i think so too i like it well i guess i
know what i'm wearing what do you look
like why do you look like a truck driver
yeah this is a trucker the truck driver
it's a truck they have the like the
shitty cheap mesh
looks like he's had like a little league
game
i don't know why
jesus christ
so i'm so curious like okay so you got
into the cosplay scene like i guess late
2000s what was the convention experience
like back then because you know
now we have a lot of boundaries that are
set with our convention you know like
you know cosplay is not consent and
everything like that
what was your experience
let's start with the question is your
first convention was what year oh so
like yes that was like the first time
that i went as like uh just on my own
was 2009 right yeah that was very like
overwhelming because i was only 19 then
and i was like it was i was there with
my friend i didn't have my parents or
anything so it was this very like oh my
gosh i'm dressed as sexy pikachu look at
all these people taking my photo oh my
god this is pretty intense but i guess
i'm just gonna smile you know but uh it
it uh that was that and then i would go
only to san diego comic con every year
uh until like 2011 i think it was okay
yeah and then i remember my first ever
guest convention was anime revolution in
vancouver which is an amazing convention
and i love everybody that runs that con
um
highly recommend oh my god okay so good
i love canadians
it's so
delicious no because like because were
you around during like the glomping era
or like the yowie
i think i just missed that but i
remember i think that was like mid-2000s
right i remember seeing yowie paddles
and being like
and then i remember like a good idea you
missed that yeah and then like the the
caramel dancing glomping
days
you know like i i i think i dodged all
that i dodged all the glomps and
everything i would see it in the halls
though with the little homestuck kids
and i'd be like what are you guys doing
you didn't miss like the free hugs era
did you free hugs
did that ever die no it still happened
no it's still happening it's just not
many people go up to them anymore yeah
yeah i think uh i don't know i i i think
i was really lucky in my convention
experience where um i i learned really
early on that i need to have people
around me to like yeah yeah and then i i
skirted around and i was kind of like
okay let's just we're gonna keep you
know yeah yeah yeah i think i think that
is pretty lucky because i
i've hear a lot of stories back there
where people did not know boundaries at
all especially when it came to like
cosplayers you know yeah i've i've been
i've been
yeah yeah well i mean that's what
started the whole like cosplay is not
consent movement yeah people are sad
that you even need to have that right
yeah yeah yeah you think it's common
knowledge but well because what people
people will do is they'll come right up
to you and they'll look at your costume
and they'll start touching your costume
and that's that's something that is like
okay what are you ready
but um but that's why like glomping was
such a nightmare when you think about it
because it's like you're literally in a
hall full of people you've never met
before yeah probably not very hygienic
either yeah and then just suddenly you
could just get
hug tackled from behind yeah and there's
nothing you could do about it what i
want to know is how it became a trend in
the first place it's it's it happens in
anime all the time do you remember like
like people would like come home and
like they'd like like in love hina there
was that one character would always like
dive bomb everybody and like and yeah
they would always get [ __ ] punched
right that yeah
that's what that was what happened in
anime yeah i feel like it's just like
you know it's like one of the only times
where anime fans feel like they can kind
of let loose yeah yeah you get like a
little bit carried away yeah definitely
yeah yeah and it's it's it's sad
there was a time where um we were we're
at a convention and uh there was a guy
and he was like filming my bum and uh
ryan just came straight up i love ryan
so much oh my god i've got scary dog
privileges with ryan he looks so scary
but he's the sweetest guy but he came
right up to the guy he was like you
can't do this right now and he was like
why not why not we're not at a
convention i can do what i want he goes
you want to we got to take you got to
leave like all right i'm calling like
ryan is like the best guardian angel you
could have had
[Laughter]
he saved me so many times um but yeah so
then the guy was like no no no and then
we had our other friend come over and he
was like nah you're out and then uh then
they he actually got kicked out which is
really great
right
yeah yeah yeah because because like i
think back then just being at an anime
convention it felt like there was
because anime was like so underground it
was so rare to meet someone else who
also like watched anime let alone like
an entire room full of people who
watched anime so i kind of felt like oh
i guess all social boundaries are like
out the window now right we're all
friends because we like the same thing
yeah yeah we're we're all animated we're
friends yeah yeah so we're all dtf right
we all like anime it's like no we're not
dtf down to friend down to france
yeah remaking down to [ __ ] down to
friends
this is worse than the two wolves being
changed yeah yeah like my two wolves i i
think you've overdone it
twice
yeah is there anything you missed about
the old school convention scene
oh probably just how much smaller it was
to be honest and then it sounds i know
that sounds a little bit like
but it's like no but it's true like the
smaller conventions i've always had a
better experience at yeah just because
it's like more like especially when
you're like within the crowd you just
feel like you're actually being involved
in the entire scene the issue with a lot
of the really big ones is that it feels
extremely corporate
like a lot of the time absolutely some
diego comic-con's become like that right
like it shifts away from showing off
actually cool [ __ ] people are interested
in yeah into hey
we're a company we want to have a spot
in this thing to show off author yeah
it's basically just turned into e3 like
yeah yeah i mean but it's like let me
show you this cool thing oh yeah and by
the way there are some cosplays here
yeah yeah i mean it happens right
because i guess if the con gets big they
come wants more money and then yeah the
evidence of business right damn you
capitalism but you know there are a lot
of cons that are like we're just not
going to go above this size we're not
going to sell any more tickets yeah this
is what it is if you get a ticket you
get a ticket yeah there's a bunch of
those in the uk as well it's pretty much
all of them in the uk i don't know i
can't think of a single except mcn i
don't really count mcm all right
anime conspiracy mtm is like a comic con
so it's a bit of everything but in terms
of anime cons in the uk the biggest it
gets is about like
a thousand people yeah and the tickets
all sell out like the first day yeah
yeah it's very hard yeah there's this
one convention that i've been dying to
go to and it's in i think it's in poland
and it's called photocon and it's you
have to like sign up beforehand to get
to it you have to be like approved and
everything and it's in this gorgeous
little town in poland and they have
access to all the different like
churches and like ruins and like fields
and stuff and you literally go there as
a cosplayer with your photographer and
just take photos for the weekend right
and it's just this like magical like
utopia of like cosplay and photographer
and i want to go so bad that sounds sick
yeah that would just be cool to like
just use as an excuse to go around cool
places in poland as well exactly even if
you're not a cosplayer just be like yeah
i just want some nice photos at a church
exactly that's why i want to go to
hawaiicon so i can like explore hawaii
oh my gosh that's i think though that's
the thing is that like personally for me
i'm just like going to use conventions
as an excuse to go travel yes that's
what we did yeah yeah we did that from
like 2012 to 2019. yeah yeah it was
amazing so like in in like your most
busy period how many conventions would
you hit up or like your job
you were going to a lot i remember yeah
so many we were like there was one year
we did like 30
or something and it was just like
were they all in america
that's more than half the year yeah yeah
it was pretty it was pretty nuts yeah
that's like that's like three
almost yeah two three a month 25 30.
yeah it was it was a lot and then there
was like some where because i remember
we went to san diego comic con they went
to like um
australia and then
we would like bounce around depending on
like what it was you know like canada we
went to spain
oh
festival unicorn i was in italy right
it's
amazing if they ever invite you it's so
amazing it's literally in this town
called vinci which is where like
leonardo da vinci like kind of grew up
okay and it's in tuscany and you get to
go to this like
oh oh it's amazing like the car i got to
wear my blood elf in this like tuscan
town and like the food is amazing who
doesn't like italian pizza
uh i think i think american pizza is
better than italian pizza
ryan
ryan agrees
i just think it's got a little more
sustenance to it it's got more weight
too i think it's two different things
entirely i i i would agree yeah but if
for me if you like have to make me
choose one i'd go for american style
wrong wrong
i'm i'm not saying that like it is
unequivocally better in any sense i just
that's what i would go two different
things
there are two pizzas inside of you
i just like how an american pizza [ __ ]
you up
you feel disgusting after like you feel
so full like an animal yeah it's yeah
it's dtf
from the scene from dodgeball where he
like shoves the pizza in his pants yeah
ryan's vegetarian so he's like he's like
oh my [ __ ] whole caesar's cheese
pizza
yeah cheese pizza is the best though
yeah like it always goes to the hardest
yep that's right except you have the
[ __ ] for the next like two days nice and
skinny
i'm not like toast i'm good
why are you getting the shits from a
pizza because it's so much cheese
lactose like you're literally [ __ ]
through a straw after a pizza
oh no it's fine it's horrible that's
your japanese jeans giving you lactose
intolerance
what
because these people don't know how to
eat pizza it's like 90 80 of uh people
are lactose intolerant
this episode is sponsored by boxer guys
summer is here and you know what that
means bathing in intense heat and
humidity now obviously it's about
heading to the beach and smashing those
watermelons am i right yes but no summer
means it's the festival season in japan
and this month bokshu brings you the
spirit of japanese festivals to your
door
is our favorite japanese snack box they
work with family businesses all over
japan and send you a new theme of
authentic treats every single month
what's the theme for this month connor
this month's theme is matsuri nights
which means festival nights i knew that
because i've watched enough anime
well guys it's time to take out your
dusty yukatas because it's the matari
episode joy what's this i got in my hand
right here that is the edomats
cake this is ningyoyaki or doll shaped
cake and it's based on a small iron mold
and filled with custard these are
actually actual bangers this is really
actually delicious yeah and i have uh
something that is part of my childhood
right here hapitan but this is uh
takoyaki flavor it's like the octopus
ball flavored ones i used to eat these
like a mofo oh wow that that legit
smells like
a [ __ ] group so if you want to try
some rare japanese snacks just click the
link in the description and use code
trash taste 15 for 15 off your first
purchase back to the episode how many
conventions have you been in like you're
like all together you reckon
because you probably out of everyone i
know you've probably been to the most
conventions yeah
yeah we we were it was it's so
fun meeting and connecting with people
right that i was just so addicted to
just
being able to like
see
the people that were just being so
[ __ ] cool online because you just
have that like natural light high energy
yeah i've noticed like when i when i saw
you in like when i saw you in hawaii at
your like signing i was like
it was like really [ __ ] professional
because you were just like you gave so
much attention and just like enthusiasm
to every single person regardless of
like how shy or not they were yeah and
then you know every now and then you'll
get those like weirdos because obviously
you're going to when you're in that
field right but like you just handled it
like a [ __ ] pro
yeah i'm i'm jealous i i wish i could be
as high energy as you because i saw one
of your signings in ax and i remember
thinking like i saw you like gave
everyone a hug you were just like so
friendly with everyone i'm like [ __ ] man
i just give it i just give people a
handshake and a picture and then i just
like that
though you know like i think i think my
my appreciation
is that's just how i
i want them to know how appreciative i
am of everything that they've given to
me i have
still probably imposter syndrome
hardcore because i feel like i was just
at the right place at the right time and
the right thing you know and so anybody
who
who wasn't there true but like i don't
know i feel like i'm i'm very of the
like put out into the world what you
want to like kind of receive
and so
that but then also just appreciating
disappointing but i do see you as
someone who is also like very
hypocritical of themselves right like
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean i guess i
guess most people in that field are like
i would say most cosplayers are right i
think i watched your documentary on
rooster teef oh you did yeah i watched
it i i had to sign up to a [ __ ]
rooster teeth membership
i cancelled i cancelled it right after i
was good
i'm sorry
there was nothing else i wanted to watch
i think i was just curious like what
what could it be like it's a documentary
i'm like well what's going on
yeah it was really good i wish it was
longer why was it so short oh cause we
were it's just like a little you like me
this time
i got a dick dug into my couch i was
ready and i'm like 30 minutes
with credits for yeah well just little
guys
it was really good yeah i a lot of the
focus was on like yeah how it must it's
hard dealing with all of the the eyes on
you yeah all the expectations and yeah
people talking [ __ ] yeah
because again like you didn't have that
gradual build that a lot of cosplayers
and just like people on the internet
have like it was literally just zero to
a hundred well i think even then it's
like now even if you are big it's like
it's such a big thing now where a lot of
people there are there are so many
cosplays over like a million followers
right yeah one hundred percent
i think when you started it was very
much not that it was yeah there was
there was a very small pocket of us that
kind of like grew yeah i feel like now
accessibility to
uh social media and just being able to
blow up on social media is so common and
other ways of monetizing it right like
there's so many ways to make money from
cosplay so much and it's it's like
really great and really
really kind of i couldn't imagine doing
what i do now in this space from scratch
today right right you you used to be
like a ruthless business person to make
it worse yeah the method is just
completely different
you have to be on that like sigma grind
set
like are you not doing that with your
parents [ __ ] just like i'm chilling
right now i'm full like like crap yeah
but like i'm just two weeks making a
cosplay i don't know yeah but that's
that's for me that's because
that's your sigma grind set yeah
okay
the fact that you're waking up every day
for like two weeks just to grind out
this
it's for the love that's not right
that's the passion you know it's just
because i want to do it yeah because i
don't know it's not like a like
the the the sigma grindset for me is um
i don't know if i can say this but
yeah only fans
the pg-13 podcast that's true we were
talking about [ __ ] pizza earlier yeah
um
because i was a great idea i wasn't sure
you were like
[ __ ] pizza
i wasn't sure what you were mainly like
being i guess
your presence was i wasn't sure i know
you have youtube you have a twitter you
i think you have patreon as well i did
for a while
yeah cause i didn't know like i just
know you as the person online cause
you're like yeah cause you're like i i
know they're no they know we're on
youtube right you know that's our thing
but i didn't know like what you're where
you were i remember your thank you yeah
i i remember when you [ __ ] upload
videos yeah yeah yeah yeah it's going oh
i did so i did mail mondays for a really
long time and they were like mail
mondays from like way back so like man
that was like the wild west back then
you could do whatever back then i was
like like hannah minx was my goddess you
remember oh yeah yeah
wherever you are
oh my gosh um so i i had to actually
have to private all my videos because a
lot of my videos were not
they're expensive like wait how much are
they a few hundred bucks
yeah what kind of what kind of thing i
don't know we're talking about
off-screen
we're still waiting for a sponsorship
from this yeah
uh what the [ __ ]
okay i remember what i was gonna ask now
oh yeah how did the [ __ ] documentary
come around like what was that all about
how did that happen so i so i did stuff
with like rooster teeth because like a
whole bunch of my friends were at
rooster teeth and everything so like
barb and all them and and then they were
just kind of like we kind of want to
just do a documentary and we want to do
like think because you're like you're a
friend of rooster teeth yeah like we
love working with you yeah let's just
do what who's jessica what was your
initial reaction to that i was like
yeah i can imagine you'd be like
not me i'm so like i was just me it was
it was really weird though because like
people were
people were kind of like like the hate
online was kind of like oh whatever
she's a [ __ ] right before the before
the thing and then after the documentary
everyone was like oh my god i see her
now
and i was like wait why did they hate
you before just cause like you know
because she was because she kind of yeah
because she kind of as well but like it
was also the fact that you just kind of
came out of nowhere and just overtook
the scene yeah right so yeah so
immediately all the eyes were on you
because it's like who is this jessica
jig and why is she everywhere yeah you
know kind of thing so like naturally
with any person it doesn't matter if
they're an absolute [ __ ] or the
nicest person ever they're gonna get
that initial this was also before there
was like this real awesome like yeah sex
workers like everything so it was like
way back when like if you dressed like
audience online then you were an
absolute cooler you know yeah so when
when everyone kind of like saw the the
documentary and everything they were
like oh she actually makes her costumes
oh
oh wait oh she got bullied oh
oh she's a human being she's a human
being a human being yeah it was it was
kind of weird because i was
not prepared for people to be okay with
me
that was an incredibly weird sensation
did you get a lot of people reaching out
being like hey long time no talk not not
like a no in like a in like a connecting
human way right right really really
interesting and i did not know how to
prepare and that was probably more tough
than dealing with like people being
dicks online no it was people being nice
you're like don't don't don't do that i
know you're lying don't give me hope
don't do they always had us in the first
time
someone's nice to you and they expect a
response it's way harder to like i feel
like formulate that response or give
them what you think they want or try and
think of just anything then yeah if
they're a dick you're like oh [ __ ] off
yeah it's
that's a really good way to explain it
yeah yeah because then you kind of go
like i'm not like what you're trying to
say yeah yeah that's easy oh yeah i can
dismiss that or whatever but then if
someone's like oh you you i really love
what you do i'm like
you have so many expectations oh my god
i hope i don't [ __ ] let you down oh
my god you sweet angel why am i going to
look after like don't look up to me oh
my god it's like i don't know if it's
growing up in england but every try
every time i try to like genuinely share
gratitude i always sound sarcastic yeah
yeah
like i'm like oh thank you so much i'm
like am i sounding sarcastic no i have
to clarify i'm not being sarcastic
yeah yeah yeah before i say anything
nice yeah that's the curse of the
british it is it is everything we say
sounds like either sarcastic or
self-deprecating like it's being in part
being like positive is just like a
[ __ ] anomaly to us well to the
american accent positivity i think yeah
do you think so oh yeah definitely yeah
like oh my god
it's so it's so it's so easy to sound
hyper-positive with an american accent
yeah yeah yeah well if you have a
british or an australian accent it's
really hard but wonderful thank you for
having me if i said that to you you'd
think like wow what did i do wrong no i
wouldn't i'd be like
i'm like i say it again like on the flip
side on the flip side
on the flip side if you see like a
negative american or something or like
someone who is an an american being
angry it just hits that much harder you
know oh right
that's why you guys can't say the c word
without it sounding like a really
[ __ ] dirty word yeah
i mean well you could do the australian
account yeah you can do the australian
ones but like but when an american says
it it's like oh
oh i understand i understand why you
can't say that jesus christ oh
[Music]
yeah we're talking about favorite scenes
i i've completely forgotten what we were
talking about before the documentary
documentary yeah so like so
were they just like hey we're gonna
[ __ ] follow you around for like a few
weeks yeah yeah so they came over and
they were like okay what's the plan i
was like um i was like okay well i'm
getting ready for booze con and i'm
going to make this costume for you yeah
remember this yeah he's going to make a
loon for blizzcon and i was i was
genuinely in the zone and it was going
to happen and i was going to work on it
and it didn't completely fell through
right and so i was like [ __ ] so then i
changed gears to alextraza and so then i
was able to [ __ ] alex graz out in like
two weeks because i don't i don't know
like powerball
you know so
that makes it sound so much more like
how many lines of code
just started like smoking weed in like
2018.
every everyone used to think that i was
like on serious drugs never done it
oh man um that's why as much as the
hawaii experience with jess was amazing
it was also the most draining experience
hanging out with jessica for more than
like three days in a row i'm just like
the film crew is just like yeah yeah i'm
like
i was like okay i now i
you suck the am out of me i'm like i
want to hang out but [ __ ] dude i'm so
tired were they were they just following
you like throughout every day they were
at your house
yeah so what they did is they they came
over and then we did like they like
drove around they're like okay would you
like to do some sort of like like we'll
go with you to get some materials and
then we can like talk about like uh like
your growing up experience and
everything new zealand stuff and then we
like did the whole costume process and
everything and then they came to
blizzcon and they filmed that stuff too
yeah
that must be weird right to have your
own documentary oh it's so weird how
would you because like how would you
reckon how would you react if someone
just came up to you was like we want to
make a dollar country about you i mean
my my biggest concern would be like
what's the angle like what are you what
are you trying to portray me as like is
it like a sympathetic thing of like woe
is me or is it like what a [ __ ]
badass sigma male grind set like he's
just like look at this look at this
monkey what would i be [ __ ] doing
sit in my room all day like i don't
[ __ ] do anything like i feel like i'd
be so bored i feel like i've got such a
crazy like obsession with like because i
got really into watching streamers over
the pandemic yeah and so um i i would
watch that i would watch that because i
want to know what like a streamer's
mentality is like when you're when
you're doing that like xqc grind you
know like eight hours a day or they are
a different breed of human yeah yeah
like you just want to pick up and just
go some some days you're just like [ __ ]
i do not want to press go live
you're like you're [ __ ] down a bunch
of coffee like
let's go it doesn't feel good when you
start though right like when you see all
the [ __ ] the chat going crazy that
shit's more serotonin than anything i
don't know why that's something like
about that all the emotions he's gone
too deep bro
so [ __ ] much yeah you're a real
streamer i can do like 12 14 hour
streams no problem that's like
i'd even need to take a break he says
that would like that would just yeah no
that's true i've done that like back to
back a few days ago
it's i don't know when you find the
right thing to stream it just feels so
like fluid and it feels so nice
yeah but that was like three days of
where i was like addicted like i
couldn't put it down and i was just like
this is so fun and it was such good
content yes yeah that's true like i've
like i've i've been streaming more often
recently and i've been doing like before
i used to like struggle to do two hour
streams and now do like sometimes four
to five hour streams but like
sometimes there are some streams that
just drain your [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
and i remember one time i was like
streaming like i think i was like going
for like an anime chat or something and
i was only like about halfway through
and i was like [ __ ] knackered so i
said i said i was like going to get like
a drink or coffee or something and then
i just left and then i just i just sat
down and i was like [ __ ] what if i just
don't come back
i think i just didn't come back for like
five minutes i lost like a thousand
viewers i was looking at my analytics i
was like why did i drop like a thousand
viewers and i was like oh yeah because i
just i just left and i'd like i just
left and didn't say i was going to come
back
with this now
that's so funny but yeah i i [ __ ]
needed that because it was just like so
[ __ ] draining yeah like i admire like
anybody who is just on a consistent
youtube schedule or like streaming
schedule like you guys just be like on
that on that grind is just it's it's
well it's it's like what you said it's
just an addiction you just love it yeah
i just like it yeah like i definitely
wouldn't be able to do what you do yeah
30 30 conventions i'd miss my home
much like i i remember it was around
2019 it was right before 2020 started me
and ryan were like
man we are burnt the [ __ ] out you know i
was like
just about to hit like 30 and i was like
bro i don't want to i don't want to do
this as much as i'm doing this anymore
like i want to go like travel and have a
good time just relax let's get a dog
let's hang out with my parents um
pandemic said everybody take a break
so it i remember
just very vividly being like i am one
thousand percent burnt out yeah and i
cannot do this anymore yeah and i had to
i had to push pause and now only after
everything like two or three years i'm
like okay i can go do it again
little little cheeky
if you weren't doing conventions what
were you doing throughout the pandemic
just chilling oh we are like any side
ventures or anything yeah i uh a lot of
stuff off uh like we're we're getting
into building a little we're gonna like
start building hobbit holes and creating
like what is a hobbit hole like like
froze one of the rings you're gonna make
one of those yeah we're gonna we're
gonna get like a property and we're
gonna build hobbit holes and like
fantasy cabins and like build this like
uh almost like an airbnb situation where
our friends can come and just like stay
make content whatever and then we're
going to like like become little old
cabin mushroom people
i want to get to that stage right yeah
that sounds like an awesome project i'm
like really excited ryan turned our
front room into a d d tavern wow
[Laughter]
he's like he's been really really keen
on doing like a bunch of like would work
kind of stuff so like that's what we
really want to do yeah he definitely
seems like a woodwork kind of guy
he gives off woodwork energy what do you
what do you guys want to do like
beyond
beyonce
be beyond
beyond what
beyond this dimension that's a good
question i feel like i'm so in the in
the thick of it right now i'm just like
i'm i'm just yeah that [ __ ] god damn it
[ __ ] hate that tick-tock noise
i'm like in the middle of it right now
i'm really just enjoying it and i feel
like i don't want to do anything else
right now
yeah that's what i like doing yeah right
right now like pretty much all of our
three schedules are like packed yeah
like with everything that we're working
on i don't have time to think about what
i want to do next because i'm
kind of doing it now meanwhile i just
started a clothing thing and i'm
dreading the fact that like my work has
just tripled
but it's so fun
but it's so fun and it's like yeah it's
worth it like yeah now i have less free
time than ever now but it's like it's
cool to do something that's just like
completely different now yeah but you
definitely have to change gears when
you're in this space too because it can
make you really like you don't want to
start getting um what's it called when
you stagnating you stagnant but also
like like you don't want to be angry at
what you're doing yeah you have to
change gears and do i just don't want to
be in like a monotonous cycle yes yeah
absolutely with like everything like i
don't want to get to the point where
it's like i know what i'm going to be
doing for the next six days because it's
going to be exactly the same as what i
did today exactly i don't want to get to
that point so it's like yeah like this
year is like by far
the busiest year of my life feels like
it's like not even not even a comparison
here
like it it feels weird that like you
know normally normally when you get
married that's like that's like
everything revolves around that for the
entire time to settle down yeah he's
trying to settle down and to me like
marriage my marriage is obviously an
amazing event but it was like only one
of the things that were planned in this
like [ __ ] massive year
um so check that off the list let's see
what else we got left right yeah ask me
again in the year and i'll probably have
a better answer yeah yeah yeah i'm
always really curious to see what other
content creators are doing with their
lives beyond like the content right
i can't see
us turning on a camera and being here
what's up you guys
next time you know like
you know
youtubers doing their thing but like but
then there's that cute guy that plays
runescape on twitch yeah i was going to
say this yeah the old guy if it makes
him happy then do it you know yeah
so i'm like i'm really really interested
to see like i i've been watching felix's
videos since he's been
yeah yeah yeah and there's just such a
feeling of like ah hell yeah dude he's
enjoying it so [ __ ] much he's making
vlogs again and i'm like i'm so happy
for him you know he's he's just doing it
with his iphone
yeah well because like i feel like
another big thing is that the past two
years have been the pandemic so i feel
like it you either went one of two ways
you either like really just use that
time to like chill out and start doing
some side gigs or some side projects
or for us we just kind of filled that
kind of void with just keeping ourselves
busy to like distract ourselves with how
depressing it was to not be able to see
our friends and stuff like that
uh and now we're just like kind of
getting out of that pandemic and we kind
of realized holy [ __ ] we are so [ __ ]
busy and we gave ourselves this schedule
in order to distract ourselves
originally and now we're like traveling
and doing all this other stuff as well
so cool i think it's so awesome i think
it's like it's so deserved like you guys
created such an incredible podcast for
people to kind of like lean on during
like the pandemic and everything and
like the people that follow you and
everything probably feel just i'm sure i
speak for them in the way that they
probably just appreciate the ever loving
[ __ ] out of what you guys have done we
just talked [ __ ] for two hours bro
awesome like that's all we do it's so
nice
this is the easy part of our job you
know exactly let's not talk about our
main channel stuff yeah right that's the
hard part we just wear stupid hats
[ __ ] you know that's that's all we do
yeah so like do you plan to go back to
more conventions now that you know
everything's opening back up again so i
really want to start doing stealthy
costumes like make full on like
unrecognizable yeah like either like
like go full on like uh do you know
ariel from diablo oh no like one of the
angels one of the archangels i'd love to
make like tyrial from the other
[Music]
[Laughter]
non-recognizable cosplay just just stuff
that like is purely like if people want
to stop and take photos it's because
they're like wow your costume is [ __ ]
sick yeah yeah and then like that's like
the the soul of it and everything yeah i
still do love making stuff i got really
into making uh
fairy houses
and like and like like just little fairy
homes what the [ __ ] what yeah it's like
small homes like little tiny houses like
i made tiny houses out of like sticks
and like mushrooms and stuff and i got
how does one get into that
how does how does one discover that to
begin with i got hardcore
yeah like tiny
little like i would make little tables
and chairs like the most ryan ryan i've
started cooking meth all right
yeah i'm retired this is the most
coveted pandemic hobby like i've ever
heard in my life so i started making
fairy houses guys dude it was so
therapeutic i loved it and then it's
like all the people who started knitting
durian
oh i got really into plants so every
time i got really depressed i would
probably get it
into plants as well
huge fairy garden room now and i was
like that was really good everyone
turned into
everyone turned into a plant mom during
the year yeah yeah yeah and then uh oh
my gosh but yeah so like that's kind of
like where the thing is like the fairy
house is kind of like blend into like
the hobbit holes and like right right
creating stuff is still something i want
to do in the future but just like maybe
not necessarily like in front of camera
yeah make sense just to like make stuff
i think i remember
you were telling me or aki
uh because i think we were just in a
casual conversation we had a similar
like conversation asking like what would
you want to do after cosplaying yeah
right because it's like you know i think
it goes without saying that like
cosplaying
in retrospect doesn't have as long of a
lifespan yeah for people right
especially because you know once people
start to get a little bit older it gets
a little more difficult to cosplay
certain characters
so it's like but i think i remember and
correct me if i'm wrong in this but you
were like i want to get into like a
manager like type position where you
like manage cosplayers and stuff like
that yeah there was a time where i was
thinking about that
and then i was like that's [ __ ]
stupid
and i was like oh do i really want to
manage people and i was like maybe i
could like fund a management company and
then like people like want to do it like
for like for sure but like oh okay
because i'm glad you said that now
because i remember when you told me that
time i responded to being like yeah that
sounds like a great idea but in my head
i'm like she can't be a [ __ ] man
not me
that's not you no i don't want to manage
people
right yeah
[Laughter]
how do you feel like the cosplay season
has changed since you started oh my gosh
um tick tock has made it so
huge
did you take talk as well not really i
have a little tick tock it's got like a
hundred thousand people on it but like
it's mostly just like kado and then like
yeah yeah fun like
travel videos yeah but um no i think
tick tock is i
i love tick tock and i love consuming
tick tock i don't want to create fork
tik tok
because i want it to be this pure like
untempered like meme stream that i can
just kind of like go and like enjoy
you don't want to ruin the platform for
yourself yeah exactly like i don't want
to look at it be like oh i don't want to
go on tick-tock because i have to create
for it you know i just don't know what i
would create
right that's like my main issues it's
like i'm yeah i feel like you guys could
do the you guys could do the cool little
like stream stream clip things yeah we
do that
we do that already yeah we do that for
trash taste but it's like for me
personally i'm like i don't know
what i would do i use my personal
streams oh okay it works pretty well
yeah that's awesome
that's the way to grow these days tick
tock is like the the avenue
yep that's the hat that's how you do it
the zoomers are got it
the kids
they're the kitties
they're so grateful for zoomers
no i tell you man they like being in a
and being in the space
like with zoomers and like
am i talking about you yeah yeah
yeah so like being in the like creative
space with zoomers and millennials and
stuff like that is really interesting
because they can teach us so many things
and they can keep us like on top of our
[ __ ] and they can also like motivate the
crap out of you yeah yeah what you're
doing you know they have the enthusiasm
that you lost over the years yeah
i had that one day yeah i remember i
remember when i was i was on that
superman
they just inspire me like crazy
especially the uh the the the cosplayers
and stuff like that yeah yeah they'll
like start the call they'll start the
tick tock like without any makeup and
then they'll go take the video
do their makeup for the video as the
video is rolling and then get into the
costume all for one video and have it
all just on tick tock the whole time
yeah like while they're doing it i'm
just like you're just amazing you're
amazing you're glorious you're fantastic
you're queens all of you i [ __ ] love
you you're so intense do you feel like
the barf quality has been like stepped
up over the years in terms of cosplay
definitely think cosplay
now for tick tock in particular not
talking about the crafting aspect yeah
the crafting aspect [ __ ] yes it's like
accelerated as far as like tick tock
cosplay it's more like you have to be
the character and do the like you have
to embody the character yeah yeah yeah
you have to really present yourself as
like a content creator that is also a
cosplayer right right how long would you
say it takes like learn the skills that
you have or like the kind of like the
average skill level that you see on tick
tock or some some of like the higher oh
right because like because
i feel like a majority of people
on tick tock who like do the they crank
out their things and stuff are doing
like purchase costumes maybe right and
then like there are the there is the
crafters as well who like put that stuff
but i think it takes i don't know it
really depends on like yeah because i'm
sure like get to get to the skill set of
like kamui for example yeah it's like
[ __ ] decades right like just getting
to the point where you just start
building your own armor yeah yeah
there's also like like some there's some
really talented makeup artist as well
like i'm just like [ __ ] man like this is
an actual artist i'm looking at with
someone like they don't have to cost
they don't have to make a costume no no
no no no you guys cosplay just with the
face yeah yeah exactly it's [ __ ]
incredible you guys seen that guy who
does like the real meme cosplays and
he's like he'll like paint his butt yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i love that it's like the cheap cosplay
the southeast asian guy right yeah oh
yeah that guy is awesome
he's not he's actually thai actually oh
really
shout out to my thai bro so since you've
been to like so many conventions right
like you must have some [ __ ] insane
convention stories oh my god i when i
heard about your guys's experience with
the the guy yeah yeah it reminded me of
the time that i also had someone do that
to us wait what we were yeah we were in
um this wonderful convention
hall we were we were in a church they
had the panel in a church what um
yeah it was it was really awesome
it was really cool and uh we were and we
were doing this panel in this church i
was dressed as a [ __ ] elf perfect
yeah
um and we were doing our our panel and
stuff when we were just sitting up there
and um this guy puts his hand up and he
goes oh can i give you something and it
was like quite quite a small little like
room you know
whatever and i was like oh yeah sure
sure and he goes i was like what is it
like as he was walking towards the stage
and he goes it's a bomb
and then bolts for the stage
and literally these two giant like
security guys just went
and grabbed him and i was like
what the
[ __ ] was it actually no so they grab him
and he goes i'm just kidding it's
cookies
and i said i'm american
i don't think in any country no that
would
be okay
and then i think he like left and stuff
but it was just such a
it was such a like
like what are you doing buddy like what
are you doing like what do you do other
than [ __ ]
how did he plan in his head for that to
go down like what was his like he must
have been like this is going to be
hilarious like here comes the punchline
yeah no it's a bomb bomb cookies
he just got tackled before he could say
the punches
[Laughter]
ryan's got really good memory because he
he's like someone has to deal with it
yeah
i remember the one uh that you told me
ages ago of the guy who came to a house
to deliver something oh my god there was
a guy oh my i love ryan
this made me this story made me gay for
ryan yeah right um so this guy so we're
we're at my house it's like my old house
um and we're just chilling around and
we're with our friend jono and jonna's
like a little bro from la jolla and uh
someone knocks on the knocks on the
doorbell and um there knocks on the door
we open the door and he goes this person
goes i have a package for jessica this
is jessica's house and he goes yeah and
the guy's like dressed as like a courier
he goes okay and he like takes the
package he goes just to be sure this is
jessica's house right jessica nigri and
he goes yeah yeah like i don't know and
then he like closes the door he gives us
the package and we're like what the hell
was that he was like i don't know just a
guy and i was like okay we took the
package no labels or anything on it
nothing on the labels um
i open up the package inside the package
is a
premonition
it's a story of someone saying jessica
this person is going to come into your
life and this person is going to offer
you a business deal and you are going to
take that business deal and you're going
to have the best business experience in
your entire life if you take this
business like a [ __ ] rosetta stone
what was it yeah what was this what was
this
i don't know it was it was weird and
then i was like i put it back in and i
was like what did what the [ __ ] because
there was no labels on anything and this
was not shipped yeah
yeah ryan
ryan knows what's up he's got like the
sixth cents for this [ __ ] yeah so he
goes what the hell was that what the
hell was that what is that and he just
gets up he goes out the door and me and
john were sitting on the couch like oh
ryan's moving ryan's on the move ryan
goes down the street tackles this guy
gets this guy in a headlock yeah and he
goes yeah why are you here yeah like
what's going on he goes i i i bought her
address off of website i bought it like
i just wanted to give her the package
and he was like what he goes do you have
a weapon on you and he goes no no no i'm
from canada i flew from canada i just
came from the airport
what though yeah and then ryan was like
oh my god and then he puts him down he
goes don't [ __ ] move okay and the
neighbors like see him like see the
altercation and everything then the
neighbor comes out and the neighbor goes
is everything okay and he goes can you
please call the cops
like this guy can you just call the cops
and they never goes why and he goes just
please can you call the cops and the
kids like sitting on the ground or
whatever
the cops come
they talk to this kid and they say like
like look you can't you did you
technically can't come here you can't do
that yeah yeah yeah and like uh the cop
told ryan he's like technically i can't
do anything but i can scare him if you
want
ryan was like yes please would you like
to see his pants
i imagine they're getting tackled is
already pretty funny yeah yeah yeah
getting tackled by ryan would be [ __ ]
terrifying
um
but really hard for you
me um so so then he like he like that
the cop gave him a talking to and
everything and then he like got an uber
and like walked away how old is this kid
bro this kid had been like teenagers
geez 21 22. well down bad dude just like
so many things started running through
my mind
you bought the address online yeah yeah
you flew from canada to come down here
and do this and you came up to the door
you you could have like
just so many things just why just why
and then that's when we went oh okay
this is really serious like we're
actually quite like not to be like oh
we're quite popular like we have a large
following yeah we need to start doing
something yeah so
we started like doing the whole like
internet scrub of everything like right
you do all the things to like to take
care of like your home and like your
address and everything like that yeah
don't [ __ ] do that yeah
this is that obviously uh in case we
need to spell it out that is not cool
you do not do that it's worrying that
there is a website that sells addresses
of
youtubers to find well that means
there's a lot of websites that do it
just because like maybe your information
was leaked by some website or something
it's right it's just a database
we have a bunch of addresses yeah you
can search for a name and it'll come up
yeah because it hasn't like the you know
a lot of countries have worked because
if you if you vote a lot of the time
that's public in a lot of countries so
your name has to be publicly registered
with an address yeah which is really
concerning yeah yeah just don't just
leave it just just leave it
i think the the thing it was an amaranth
just recently oh that was fun that was
terrifying that is what happened without
uh uh so yeah dude flew from uh estonia
yeah uh it wasn't it wasn't our editor
luckily
uh there are more people who live in
estonia than just one of the two one of
the superstars
oh there you say it flew from estonia
and was live streaming himself outside
her house like waiting like the entire
time and like it started to gain a bit
of popularity of people watching him
because i think people were it's
probably that sick thing of like what
[ __ ] up thing is he gonna try and do
yeah i'm gonna watch yeah and uh yeah
luckily uh he got arrested uh before
yeah rightfully so yeah
but like my god flying from estonia and
just and he was there for like a month
he was there for a long time waiting
outside of her house yeah yeah who done
come get your mans mood
get your man is that your bands
look like there's there and then there's
the one from uh i've got gav
yeah yeah and also obviously uh
christina grimmie chris
dude i just don't know
it's it's terrifying like that's another
thing that me and ryan also kind of
really considered when we were um
starting to not do conventions anymore
is because there were some moments and
some messages that we were getting to
that we were just like you know yeah i
don't think it's going to be worth it
yeah yeah these conventions aren't going
to be taking the precautions that they
need to be taking a lot of them and i
think it's because there's a vast
disconnect of understanding of how a
popular creator online can draw such a
huge audience and become such a
influential part of a convention
experience right you know because i i
saw like the video and like everything
like you guys had a massive [ __ ]
panel yeah like you guys are about to go
to anime expo it's gonna be [ __ ] huge
yeah yeah no and like i would say that
like there are times where these online
creators and like everything are have
way bigger lines and way bigger like
presents than like traditional media oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah surprises the [ __ ]
out of me that people are still not up
to date with the fact that
you guys are it's like 10 years this
yeah the convention's still kind of yeah
yeah there was a time i went to a
convention and uh i had like a huge line
and i was next to i can't i don't want
to say it wasn't yeah yeah but he came
over to me after and he goes he goes so
what do you do like like
what what are you doing what are you
dressed up as kindred like what i was
dressed as kindred from
legend
what is this and i was like oh i'm a
cosplayer and i was like all excited to
tell him and he goes oh okay
okay
oh i think there's a lot of forces at
play right like there's a lot of like
traditional agents putting pressure on
the con to be like yeah these are the
a [ __ ] about people
and you've got like your team's like oh
we got like this cosplayer like yeah you
like the and then the
conventions i think but we got the guy
who plays an extra in star wars
why are you pampering him up yeah
i mean i guess we're just starting to
experience this now i mean like i think
like mcm we've talked about this before
but mcn was like a real eye-opener for
us yeah in terms of what we need for
like our convention experience we've
been to conventions before just as our
own stuff but like it was
not even close to the same level yeah
yeah exactly yeah
how cool though like yeah
it's
exciting as it is scary yes yeah yeah
yeah what do you guys think you're going
to do going forward or what do you think
you would like suggest say if there's a
convention watching and they're like
what would you suggest
proper security give us security
stop looking down on youtubers
this episode is sponsored by tipsy tipsy
for those of you who don't know is the
us's largest online sake store carrying
over 400 labels all decoded into an easy
to grasp format so with tipsy if you
become a member every three months you
get six new sake that they curate for
you look at this look at all these
bottles right here yes well as the token
uh sake expert here on trash takes let
me just touch upon a couple of the ones
that you guys might be interested in
okay so one that i personally recommend
right here is the toyo vision
this particular brew gives an aroma red
apple that fades to an almost nutmeg
spice oh wow okay we also have the
takenotsuki the yukihonuka right there
this suck is locally produced using
mountain dew water collected from a deep
well and dewanosato rice and don't worry
if you know nothing about sake because
it comes with a nice tipsy sake guide
for beginners connor this one's for you
thanks i need that actually
and for every single tipsy member you
will get unlimited free shipping so if
you're interested in tipsy make sure to
check it out by clicking the link down
in the description below and thank you
to tipsy for sponsoring this episode
drink responsibly so yeah i mean like we
haven't gone to the event now but by the
time that uh this episode comes out we
would have already been to anime expo
and uh having to deal with them
in terms of explaining the fact that we
need security is just didn't go through
at all so they
uh we asked for security after our
incident at mcm and after our experience
at mcm and uh they kind of just refuse
to
give us any i mean mind you we're guests
yeah at this conference
we're official guests at anime expo and
they were like
i think what they said was singing along
lines of there's
security at the con so why would you
need
yeah why would you need any additional
ones but then we won't have anyone like
with us yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and that's and
that's all we said and you know we even
said like hey we had this incident at
mcm where unfortunately security was not
present we don't want the same thing
happening at amex but because or future
cons in general right yeah and they were
like
sounds like your problem bro yeah so we
just pay for it so we have to pay for
our
cool but own security
because the if if the com was like hey
we gave you like a [ __ ] ton of money you
can you know for coming then it'd be
like okay well all right but animation
doesn't pay guests yeah i uh i was
talking to um when we were we went to
gamescom in germany yeah that one's
[ __ ] awesome but we were we were with
blizzard and blizzard gave us these two
gigantic lads to take care of us and
they were oh my god i'm still friends
with them on instagram
oh my god these these guys are so
awesome i wonder if it's like a if it's
like a if it's a disconnect with the
whole like hollywood thing in america
right maybe and then like because when
we were in
speak your mind i heard it no i i'm i'm
going i'm just yeah i i was thinking
maybe but that still wouldn't be an
excuse that's true yeah you're right i
do think it's still just that disgusting
it's it's like also and i think it there
is this weird kind of sense of if
we admit that you're you will bring in
these crowds and we kind of say hey
you're worth that much it means that
they have to then pay you more yeah they
have to offer you more things yeah and
so there is that kind of i at least i
get the sense of like we don't want to
be like wow you're such a big deal or
something like that
because we don't want to have to then
step of what we have to do yeah
i feel i think so i'm sure you maybe
think that way when you
kind of feel the interactions you've had
yes were you trying to explain things
and they'll be like yeah but we think we
we know what's going on there's also
that like whole like um like exposure
type
i don't want to say like youtube
paid by exposure this is nonsense
because like
ultimately the algorithm at like tick
tock at twitter and youtube is could get
you so so so much more exposure than any
amount of people you could meet at a
convention you might make stronger
connections and you might make more
worthwhile yeah viewers yes but in terms
of like growth and actually like is it
worth like five days or six days right
not really like after a certain point
it's not worth it i do wonder too
because like there are some things that
i've done in my like career that i was
like i'm just gonna do it i don't care
if you pay me or not because it gets
your foot in the door no definitely and
so then it kind of gets you to that
point where you're just like i'm i'm i'm
down like they're like oh get jess she's
down to do it kind of thing but i'm sure
i'm sure that worked because that was
like very early in that kind of 100 yeah
like now it's just like you know it's
it's that's the old school method of
doing things
i mean it's literally you know there's a
big issue with artists getting paid in
just exposure right yeah
um and you know there is like some
benefits to it early on in your career
but like when you're established you
know you've got you've got there's a
part of professionalism that you've got
to like expect from it right yeah
exactly yeah so yeah so it's i wonder if
a lot of conventions are operating in
that like oh you're just a youtuber come
on you'll do it there's something sure
there are some not not everyone but like
it depends right on who's running it as
well because a lot a lot of the cons
more often not they're like i really
like this person or i'm a big fan i want
to get them yeah and if it's you that's
great yeah but if they're a fan of older
media and stuff and they don't give a
[ __ ] about youtube it's it is like
pulling teeth yeah there is a blatant
bias definitely oh yeah
it's understandable i'm like if it's
your con i guess i get it like yeah you
don't want [ __ ] me there that's
totally fine like yeah i'm not like
you know i live i'll live well that's
why we're going on tour right yeah oh
yeah
can we talk about that i mean it should
have been already announced
yeah it should be announced by the time
okay this comes out but uh yeah let's do
it ourselves yeah we'll just wait do it
ourselves yeah we just like we just got
to the point where just like okay yeah
cons are cool you know we've been doing
it for a while but now it's like it's
like the new meta i guess to do
something yourself to do something
ourselves right like it's like it's just
become commonplace now for youtubers to
do tours um the otk game thing did you
guys see that yeah
that was awesome yeah yeah yeah i love
that like like our our generation our
group of like uh creators and stuff like
that are just going like we're just
gonna make our own [ __ ] yeah yeah which
is like so amazing like you're taking
the power from way from like the old
media stuff you're just putting in your
own i mean i mean i think it has gotten
to a point where you do have enough
influence in reach to be able to and
you've as an influencer you get used to
big companies treating you like [ __ ]
because you are an influencer
you know know
they kind of like they kind of look down
on you compared to like old traditional
media but then in reality a lot of
people a lot of big mainstream content
creators have the power and reach to
make their own [ __ ] like events and
be even bigger than the the ones that
are run by big official companies
and yeah i mean i don't know how much
it's going to take for like companies to
realize that hey
people watch creators people follow
influencers you know it's people want to
go see creators irl yeah not just online
exactly would you guys do the creator
clash
uh i wouldn't personally because i don't
i i would i would i would consider it i
think i kind of want to get beat up
why not right i was uh we were at a
after party with uh minx and we did like
some little it's like a little um like a
boxing training thing where you just
have to tap the other person's shoulder
shoulder and then like dodge and i did
like this little dodgy thing and she was
like what the [ __ ] like what the [ __ ]
was that because you're jittery yeah
you just have like a natural light
i'd hate to go down i wouldn't know
what's coming yeah that's what she said
she was like she's like oh you're a
fancy boxer i'm not gonna box you [ __ ]
off
you should do it i kind of really want
to do it i just i mean you're already
fit enough yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i mean i feel like it would just be like
a good [ __ ] opportunity and it's just
an excuse to stay fit as well right yeah
get paid to get in in insane shape yeah
like the best shape of your life that
sounds awesome
a real muscly mommy
the pyramid head cosplays with abs
well
monsters in general so yeah if you guys
saw on our twitter you saw our new
mascot it's it's it's this little
adorable creature
you want to stay
yeah we this is the first animal we've
ever had on sets yeah
really how long how long have you had
how long how long have you guys had
cattle for karo we got uh right in the
beginning pandemic yeah yeah we uh we i
don't know how we got a sheba um
we randomly put our name down to a
there's a lady who does um who breed
sheba's in arizona who was living in
kyoto beforehand
right and so she moved to arizona and
so she she's like super certified
everything like that she's like super
super pro and everything but we put our
name down for him and we were just like
okay like we were thinking about maybe
having a dog and then we kind of just
went out about our lives and then she
called and she went hey um
someone backed out they don't want uh
this little little guy do you want them
when we're like we're here you're that's
our boy we're here to get you i'm
already outside
i'm saying that you you spotify
listeners are like missing out right now
man yeah spotify listeners move to
youtube right now for this scene
is he your first pet he's my yeah he's
like my first dog individual i used to
have like rats and stuff when i was a
little girl in new zealand
so did
[Laughter]
yeah like a little pet rat named sparky
yeah it was awesome what do you mean
you're not like why why why why why are
rats it's not even a mouse like a rat
yeah yeah like rats are super smart and
clever you can teach them tricks and
they're super super like just the
sweetest little little guys yes
he's figuring it out he's like releasing
me from the from the trash taste there
i would i would love to i would love to
own a dog or just any kind of pet but
just right now as god was saying it's
the busiest year of my life right now
and i just do not have the time to take
it now i was running away yeah no i i
want to get a pet
really bad
um but i would want to settle down first
before i get it yeah but like the more
that time goes on the less i know when
i'm going to be settling down so i'm
just like the like i thought i'd be like
okay i'm going to get a pet in a year
then it went to two years yeah three
years and i'm just like i'll get a pet
someday maybe when i settle down i don't
know what it's gonna be one is one of
these days because like i don't want to
be traveling a lot and like being away
from home a lot when i have a when i
have a pet i think i think we're gonna
start aki and i'm gonna start small so
we're gonna start off with like a fish
tank
yeah you know just like fish right
because like that's a rats
what do you have to do a [ __ ] rodent
why not mousy rodents
what the [ __ ] i would understand like a
mouse or like a hamster no rats are so
clever and smart i bet they are but in
your shoulder and they give you little
snuggles and kisses and they're so sweet
i think it's because like everyone's
idea of a rat is like this like a dirty
street rat yeah he said
i didn't want to do that
so cute
he's cleaning the face dude yeah i hate
that i hate that so much you hate
cleanliness yes jesus
[Laughter]
what what pet would you guys want if you
could definitely a dog definitely a dog
i was like what are you saying the other
day i want one of those she being here
yeah
the tan one or the the town sorry
oh it's the doge coin
have have you ever owned a pet no never
parents wouldn't like me really they
were like you won't look after it so you
don't have it you don't like rats you
can't have it you can't have any pets
yeah if i got a rat my parents would
have been like you're gone really no
they don't stink or anything so i'm such
a big rat advocate i think just the
thought of having a rat in your house
it's like when you watch that tlc of
that girl like a 10 year old girl who
loves cockroaches and for some reason
the parents let her have cockroaches so
just in the room there's a bunch of
cockroaches all around her she loves it
what
what would be the negative thing of
having a cockroach well like health-wise
are they
dirty would they they're not they would
breed right
the thing was there was a bunch of them
and they were clearly around the house
so the only thing that would be bad is
just that they would be there well i
mean it's just the fact that like
there's not many people they carry like
yeah and a lot of diseases yeah a lot of
diseases do they okay because i was kind
of trying to see the duality of
cockroaches you know
they would they would get married and it
would be amazing because
it would just be flossed away
it would be gutsy
oh he's bringing like the sketchy kid at
home to hang out in my house well i
would love that sketchy kid because
that's what parents should do when you
see the sketchy kid you go are you okay
at home i am looking to see if you have
enough in your bowl not if you have too
much bring in all the chlamydia all the
kara the black plague hasn't been around
for a long time it doesn't matter i'm
adopting you
collecting the infinity stone of the
thesis
i'm clearly a more patient and caring
person than myself you're british yeah
that's true i i think i think us in
europe have just been like you know
the rapture yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
look look it's it's generally
killed a third of europe
only a third of europe what do we have
against rats i don't know what's wiped
our entire [ __ ] population you know
there's still the bubonic plague it
still exists it doesn't really there's
people who still get it i think it's
like i think it's like still like it's
like two or three yeah it's like two or
three people a year in the states alone
get the black play
so so in thailand there's actually like
a lot of like street dogs right just
like roaming around and they are like
they're just [ __ ] built different
than like even done like you know like
they're from the streets yeah they are
from the streets right they lit
literally right because i remember the
first time uh cindy went to thailand she
was like oh look at all the dogs look at
that i want to take care of them all and
i'm like sydney you these are the dogs
you need to be careful of right this
this is like the [ __ ] ghetto of like
the dog the dog world right now you you
don't you do not want to bring [ __ ]
the dog steps up on a time like this
yeah yeah yeah even says like you know
you're [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah so like
obviously like a lot of dogs have like
very sensitive stomachs you really need
to like take care of what you feed them
and everything like that this is which
is why you have like specialized dog
treats and everything like that so i
remember
uh there was like a street dog just like
outside of a combini
and
sydney like cindy felt bad so she wanted
uh she wanted to like feed it right yeah
and
so what she did and i was like i was
like cindy don't do this this is a bad
idea this is this is a bad idea don't
like
you know as much of a dog as much as
even if you're a dog lover you need to
like be careful of street dogs yeah
because a lot of the times they're under
the rabies as [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
animals in general yeah yeah yeah um so
she goes in the combini and buys
buys like a pack of like dog food right
p like dry pre-packaged dog food yeah
and
she like tries to like try to like feed
feed this dog
and so she like should i pause a little
pile of of this dog food and she's like
come on come on come eat you must be
hungry and the dog comes over has one
sniff of it and just like [ __ ] off
he's like what the [ __ ] is this food
right
yeah i thought i was gonna bite at the
back no no no because yeah i was
expecting the dogs to be like
so that's like because like the dog then
like just goes around the corner and
like that there's like some like chicken
bones on the streets and he just starts
snacking on that because because
normally you can't straight to the sauce
yeah it goes straight to the sauce like
i don't want that process [ __ ] i want
yeah it's just like the dogs there are
just different and it's just so it's
kind of it's kind of it's kind of common
for like a lot of like thai houses to
have like some kind of dogs um i mean
japan's like that with cats as well
there are so many [ __ ] yeah there are
like 70 million cat islands
cat islands because they're just
so many abandoned islands especially in
the south of japan yeah are just more
cats than people now yeah and like i
went to a couple of them and yeah
they're [ __ ] cute because they're
just like cats everywhere so if you love
cats it's awesome but then you remember
they're probably infested with fleas
probably got raised yeah they're from
the streets they are these these are
like street cats they're like three
sharks
rabies scary it's scary dude [ __ ] like
babies no i've seen videos people with
it where they're trying to drink water
because you become you can't drink water
like and you know there's no cure for
rabies there's no cure you can only
prevent it from happening right but
there's nothing there's actually like no
known cure for rabies once it actually
gets into your system i think when there
was that whole scare with like uh
in the in the dc when there's a fox that
bitten people and given them it was like
a few months ago we've given a few
rabies and a bunch of videos are going
around showing like what happens and you
get it because you physically can't
drink water yeah like what do you mean
like so you try to drink it and you're
like you spit it out because your body
is just like reject it
it's horrible yes you just get like like
iv uh yeah but a lot of people just die
you die normally quite shortly after
it's really horrible disease and it's
like one of the things you're like ah
rabies and then like when you see it
you're like oh god oh god yeah yeah yeah
it's [ __ ] but everyone's just cute
adam so if you see a street animal just
admire from a distance yeah yeah you
know you can't find it funny because you
can definitely tell like sometimes it's
froth right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah but like you can
definitely tell like when you're walking
around in thailand sometimes like
someone takes a dog out on the walk and
you you can tell the difference between
like the domesticated dogs yeah and the
street dogs it's just like the the like
the domestication dog looks over and
like the street dogs are just like yo
you've come to the wrong neighborhood
man
look who's facebook
we went to tanzania to climb kilimanjaro
and then same with nepal as well we're
like it was the same thing there's
climbed kilimanjaro yeah damn dude
that's cool oh i like how she just
casually throws it up yeah just like
yeah i just like kill him jared no
biggie no my mom wanted to do it so she
was she like she brought us all over
there but uh like the dogs everywhere
around there as well same thing just so
many yeah yeah but it was kind of kind
of like nice though because the dogs
there in tanzania were like you could
tell that they could just kind of like
go into people's homes and just kind of
like go hang out because they were like
like you would see one and they would
just kind of like walk right into the
thing and then they were kind of like oh
come on up you know like how like jumps
on the stool and like in lord of the
rings i kind of do that with the right
right
right
what up why why that specifically no i
really like lord of the rings you're
valid yeah yeah you had a really weird
experience right joe because you you had
a cat as a kid right yeah something like
that i became allergic to cats i had
three cats and you became allergic and
then i became alert so it was so weird
so like i had so when i was born i had
one cat uh called marble right she was
really cute and then she she died
shortly after i was born because she was
quite an old cat so and then we got two
more cats because my parents just
[ __ ] love animals like i was
surrounded by animals my entire life
yeah so i had these two cats little guy
in pocky um and i had them till i was
maybe like 10 or 11 years old yeah and
then
just completely coincidentally like two
weeks after
my last cat pocky had passed away i was
gonna go get an allergy test
right because i'd never got one in my
life so my mom was just curious being
like i wonder if you have any food
allergies or you know medicinal animal
allergies or whatever and because it's
free in australia right so it's like
yeah [ __ ] it let's go so i went to go
get it and then i did the test and i
remember specifically there was one part
of my arm that was really [ __ ] itchy
yeah i was just like oh [ __ ] like yeah i
definitely have an allergy towards
something yeah i don't know what it is
and then the doctor came in they were
like yeah so you're allergic to cats
and i was like
that doesn't make sense i had a cat up
until two weeks ago yeah the doctor
explained that apparently it's like a
thing where if you're surrounded by a
certain allergenic for your entire life
and then suddenly it gets cut off your
body has like a whiplash effect where
you can actually develop an allergy for
i again i'm not a doctor i don't know
how let me tell you let me tell you what
happened joey yeah your body was like i
will never love another cat again yeah
i
am not allowed to love any more cats
dude
that's honestly probably what happens
which sucks because i [ __ ] love cats
and it's like and and now like you know
over time like i've just grown to like
get allergic to like all sorts of
different animals do you feel any like
ever itchy nose when you put your like
face into cardo at all so okay so for
dogs and some other animals it depends
so like with dogs i'm allergic to some
breeds
but not others i'm probably okay with
counter wonder because normally i would
be sniffling like a [ __ ] right
now but i've gotten pretty close to him
already like he was sitting here just a
moment ago and i'm completely fine okay
yeah so i think i'm okay with him but
like some other like long-haired dogs
for instance the moment i entered like
it got so bad to the point i remember in
high school where i went to a friend's
house for the first time and i started
sniffling outside of his house and i
said do you have a dog in your house and
he was like yeah how did you know
because i because i'm [ __ ] dying
right now super power yeah like my
sinuses are getting destroyed right now
and so i could tell immediately
yeah i like i just i used to i have
hated cats for so long and only recently
have i met a couple of really sweet cats
and i'm just like oh my [ __ ] god oh i
mean like wrong
i'm allergic
to join the club
it was so [ __ ] annoying i was like oh
you're just the sweetest little baby and
i love you it was like a little stray
that we found and then we like we got
him a new home but we had to give him
away because i would i put my face into
him and he was like drooling on me and i
was like i don't [ __ ] care
get out of there
that's rare because like 99 of the time
cats are [ __ ]
they are [ __ ] they're such [ __ ]
creatures but there's something about
them we just like it's because i'll
forgive you yeah it's a hard level game
the reason why people like cats is
because if that cat likes you and nobody
else that's something then it's like
[ __ ] yeah i'll tell you what it is cats
are just catch is just the tsunderes of
the anime
right right right you're like you
[ __ ] they [ __ ] why do you want a
dog you should have a cat
i want a cat as well honestly like i
don't
know
that's like a syndra dog yeah yeah yeah
that's why that's why i want to shiba
actually yeah i don't know it's just
like i i get it because like you know
they're like [ __ ] moody teenagers a
lot of the time black cats right they're
just like they just do their own [ __ ]
but then the moment they show a slight
bit of like love towards you yeah yeah
yeah yeah
you little [ __ ]
like your little dick
actually actually there's uh we uh in my
house in england uh we have like the
neighbor has a cat right but it like
comes into our garden so often
that uh me and sydney just like we
didn't know what his name was so we kind
of just like gave it a name right yeah
yeah so i don't know why how this name
came about where we just started calling
her scarlett joe
this poor cat has a identity issue
so i don't know who i am yeah and
initially initially she would come over
and she'd see us and she would like
[ __ ] scuttle off or something and
then and then slowly but surely like
she'd come over to our like garden so
often that you know we you know we
started like trying to give her a little
bit of attention at first she was like
no
get the [ __ ] away from me get away from
me get away from me all right right
and then like what happened was we moved
to thailand me and sydney moved to
thailand right
and
uh and after we had come back to england
for like for like a quick trip we'd go
outside
and then scarlett joe just [ __ ] bolts
it towards us to be like oh oh my god
where are you i'm like that was the
first time we were able to pet her and
we were
and then we were able to pet her for
like a four or five minutes and then she
was like all right i don't like you
anymore
the honeymoon phases yeah the honeymoon
phase is over but it happens like it
happens every time now where we go away
we come back to england and she sees us
she's like for the first like for the
first meeting she's like so excited and
i'm like yes i live for this i live for
this you totally just reminded me this
is the most australian story i have but
we had that exact same experience in our
neighborhood right but instead of a cat
it was a rock wallaby
what's a rock wall over here so think of
think of a kangaroo but like miniature
size
and it's just these like wallabies that
just like that like they just hop around
in the forest like along like rocks like
structures and we had one because like i
live right next to like a national park
yeah so it was like just my backyard was
a national park so like every now and
then we would just see this rock wall be
on
like on the street
and we're like oh that's like oh that's
really cute you know but you know but it
was no biggie right because it's like
national parks right there you know
whatever but then like the more i saw it
the more it would like get closer to me
yeah and get more comfortable with me
even though i wasn't doing anything
right i was like
yeah i would walk yeah i would have
walked back home from school and they
would just be like the rock will be i'm
like oh you're a lot closer than last
time so i'm like maybe i can pet him
maybe
i can muster up the energy to pet him so
i remember one day yeah i was as i was
coming back from school same [ __ ]
rock wallaby like hops over i was like
i'm gonna go towards it
i'm gonna i'm gonna try my chances but
like because it's a rock wallaby right
they're really [ __ ] like cautious
they're like the squirrels of australia
yeah yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] mini
kangaroo yeah
but like like squirrels are kind of the
same thing where they're like sometimes
they'll come close to you because
they're a little curious they'll never
let you pat them but they'll never let
you pay yeah yeah yeah so i was like so
i got close and it was it'd be like oh
step back [ __ ]
like we're cool but we're not that cool
yeah yeah you know but then eventually
it got to the point where i got one pet
in
and i was like yes
it was the best feeling i was like mom
can we can we have the wrong one with me
i want it as a pen
but uh yeah you can't do that in
australia unfortunately but i remember
that you're addicted to the to the the
energy of petting like we just love
animals
you were saying before like australians
just are good with animals
i feel like you have to be to survive
though you know that's that's like not a
symbiotic relationship yeah yeah yeah
exactly
it's like we won't [ __ ] with you as long
as you don't [ __ ] with us that's what it
is yeah every time i'm like scrolling on
tick tock and i see some australian guy
[ __ ] with like a like an animal yeah
he's like he'll have like a full-on
tarantula on his leg and he'll be like
oh you're right matt you're right all
right sometimes these guys get a little
bit in your house you're just gonna let
him go he's like put him down you know
he's like all right see ya and then
everyone in the comments like what a
[ __ ] gig a chat
no he's just a stream yeah
you guys are like that [ __ ]
what are those like [ __ ] guy like
creatures called in like avatar
whether like have to be like one with
nature right in order to survive sorry
wait what kind of avatar are you talking
about
i think james cameron james cameron
avatar
i think you've been talking about this
i should have said james cameron yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly right
off my heart because i [ __ ] love
avatar and i want to be in it that's the
blue that's the blueprint
i'm excited for avatar too
okay look
are you the reason james cameron is
still like i promise there's gonna be
four of them oh four okay like the only
thing that i think okay i love the idea
of aliens and just like leaving and then
dipping and i love the old like i build
fairy houses i love nature like i want
to have a property and like live out in
the forest you know this is like my jam
on steroids obviously it's going to be
bad
i'm still going to watch it because i
hope it's not bad because he's hyped
this [ __ ] up more than anything the fact
that just i just want to see what people
are able to do with like the animation
and everything nowadays yeah well i mean
the other movie that he kind of helped
with uh
the anime adaptation movie that he
didn't direct but he had he kind of
helped what's that one oh love death and
rose no no no no
he worked a lot with the people who did
it uh and so i think if it's that good
quality alita was really [ __ ] good
looking
yeah
yeah it looked awesome
i didn't see it they look [ __ ]
awesome it was all right i mean it was i
liked it i thought leader was really
good it was it was a good film what i
want them to do is i want this stuff to
go well with this kind of animation so
they could redo the world of warcraft
movie completely animated
and they can redo the halo
series completely animated
i mean the halo one was rough i
look does halo even have a good
storyline to adapt actually yeah it kind
of does it's kind of a sick one i've
never paid attention to it it's a really
cool world concept
yeah it's a shame they turn into this
[ __ ] mediocre [ __ ] fest they just
gotta take chief actual cheese yeah and
like animate little tiny cortana and
like all that stuff and then yeah yeah
there's a lot of politics in halo like a
lot a lot of politics it works
[ __ ] sex yeah
ryan has the mark of shame on the back
of his legs no way
oh yeah i could love all the arbiter
memes
i think it's time to finish yeah i think
i think like who wants to make like a
compilation of just like jessica noses
although you've made on this podcast
thank you so much for watching this
episode of trash tag hey look at all
these patrons though oh my god do you
see them all pick your favorite
can i grab this one oh man good luck
with that
i love you
but hey if you'd like to be eaten by
justin hickory then make sure to go over
to our patreon patreon.com
also follow us on twitter send us some
memes on the subreddit and if you had
our face listen to us on spotify and uh
is it is there anything you want to
shout out i don't have to tell you go
check out jesus be good to each other be
kind life is short you don't know what's
going to happen so enjoy every moment
okay we'll leave her stuff in the
description
i thought you were just going to shout
and hopefully you guys enjoyed this
episode we'll see in the next one
[Music]
you